BACK INTO ORDER PUBLIC SAFETY
COMMITTEE -- WE NEED -- MISS
SKINNER.
OS TWO BILLS [inaudible]
ANDMISTER WEINER IF HE WANTS TO
FINISH OUT THE DAY WE HAVE ONE
OF HIS BILLS LEFT [inaudible]
BUG [inaudible]
MR PORTANTINO.
POSTPONED HIS LAST BILL UNTIL
JULY NINTH
.
SERGEANT COULD YOU CALL MISS
SKINNER'S OFFICE --
PLACES ARE
[inaudible]
RESEARCHERS [inaudible]
YES.
WHICH IS A WE HAVE THE PLEASURE.
OF THE CHAIR OF SENATE PUBLIC
SAFETY.
GRAY SEEN OUR IS STEAM CHAMBERS
[inaudible]
YEAH. TWO ITEMS SB FORTY TWO SB
THREE NINE FOUR ITEMS NUMBER
THREE AND NUMBER [inaudible]
NINETEEN OKAY [inaudible]
SHE'S.
THANK YOU CHAIR WON'T SKINNER
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY YOU MAY
PROCEED YES THANK YOU -- WE'RE
PRESENTING SB -- FORTY TWO THE
GETTING HOME SAFE ACT.
AND THIS BILL.
IT MAKES A LOT OF SENSE
REGARDLESS OF WHAT HAPPENED BUT
IT WAS INSPIRED AND NOW I DON'T
I DON'T SEE INSPIRED THAT'S NOT
EVEN IF THE APPROPRIATE THING TO
SAY I SHOULD REALLY SAY IS THAT
THERE WAS A HORRIBLE TRAGEDY.
IN MY AREA.
WHERE -- JESSICA ST LOUIS A
WOMAN WHO WOULD IT WAS ONLY IN --
JAIL FOR SHORT PERIOD OF TIME.
WAS RELEASED FROM JAIL AT ONE IN
THE MORNING WITH A BART TICKET
YOU KNOW THE BAY AREA BARGES ARE
TRANSIT SYSTEM HE DOESN'T RUN.
TWENTY FOUR SEVEN IT DOESN'T
START AGAIN UNTIL MORNING FIVE
AM OR SO.
SO SHE'S GIVEN OF OUR TICKET SHE
HAS NOTHING ELSE.
AND D..
BART IS RELATIVELY CLOSE TO
ALAMEDA COUNTY JAIL TO SANTA
RITA IT'S ABOUT A LITTLE MORE
THAN HALF A MILE.
BUT IT'S VERY DESOLATE BETWEEN
WHERE THE BARGES IN THE JAIL.
BECAUSE A LUIS WAS FOUND DEAD.
BEFORE PART EVEN OPENED.
AND HEY TO TO HAVE THIS WAS AN
AVOIDABLE TRAGEDY THIS WAS A
DEATH SHOULDN'T HAVE HAPPENED.
AND TO RELEASE PEOPLE WHEN
WITHOUT GIVING THEM THE ABILITY
TO CALL SOMEONE TO GET A RIDE
WERE NOT MAKING YOU KNOW IF THEY
DON'T HAVE A WORKING CELL PHONE
ANY NUMBER OF THINGS.
JUST RELEASING THEM DURING
NORMAL BUSINESS HOURS ALL OF
THOSE THINGS WOULD HELP AVOID
SUCH DEATHS JUST BECAUSE ST
LOUIS IS NOT THE ONLY PERSON WHO
HAS DIED WITHIN A SHORT TIME OF
BEING RELEASED.
IN THE MIDDLE OF THE NIGHT -- SO
THAT'S WHAT THE BILL DOES AND I
CAN GO THROUGH ALL THE LITTLE
DETAILS BATES IN YOUR ANALYSIS
AND NOW I'D LIKE TO HAVE MY
WITNESSES SPEAK IN SUPPORT AND I
HAVE SUSAN BURTON NEW WAY OF
LIFE.
AND CRISTINA NERVE OURS -- THANK
YOU SENATOR. SIX AND I WANT TO
THANK ALL THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS
REGGIE -- MAKES YOU SPEAK INTO
THE MIKE SPEAK INTO THE MIKE ONE
HEAR EVERY WORD YOU HAVE TO SAY
EVERY WORD I HAVE TO SAY.
I WAS THINKING NUYS INJURES
SKINNER AND I WANT TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE FOR HEARING THIS VIA
AN ON YOU ASSEMBLY MAN SAW YOUR
FOR ALL THE WORK THAT YOU DO
HERE.
I'M FOUNDER OF THE NEW WAY OF
LIFE REENTRY PROJECT THAT ON
THAT PROVIDE THREE ENTRY
SERVICES FOR WOMEN EVEN
PRISONERS IN JAILS.
ARE FROM ALL OVER CALIFORNIA.
I STARTED A NEW WAY OF LIFE BACK
IN NINETEEN NINETY EIGHT
FOLLOWING MY OWN PRISON
EXPERIENCE.
YOU KNOW.
AS A FORM INCARCERATED ONE MAN.
I REMEMBER BEING RELEASED --
FROM FROM CIVIL BRAND AT THE
TIME AT ALL HOURS OF THE NIGHT.
I STILL TODAY RECEIVE CALLS FROM
WOMEN BEING RELEASED AT ALL
HOURS OF THE NIGHT [inaudible]
I MEAN.
IT'S NOT.
LIKE ROCKET SCIENCE [inaudible]
DAD -- PEOPLE.
I SHARES COULD SEE THE
VULNERABILITY OF WOMEN
[inaudible]
AND ALSO [inaudible]
THEIR HUMANITY. TO RECEIVE
SUPPORTS IN RELEASES THAT HOURS
THAT WOULD ALLOW THEM TO ACCESS
SERVICES.
AND ACCESS SUPPORTED NOT BE LET
OUT IN THE DARK OF THE NIGHT.
I'M IN TOTAL SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL -- DAD WE WOULD INSURE
PEOPLE WOMEN [inaudible]
GET RELEASED.
AT A TIME THAT THEY CAN ASK SEX
ACCESS SERVICES.
AND NOT BE VULNERABLE -- SO
THAT'S YOU KNOW WHAT I HAVE TO
SAY AND I'M THANKFUL THAT THIS
BILL IS CAME ABOUT -- IT'S IT'S
DIFFICULT TO THINK THAT WE WOULD
NEED TO BE ABLE TO DO THIS.
THAT IS JUST YOU KNOW -- SORT OF
LIKE DOCUMENTS COMMONSENSE
AROUND WHAT WE SHOULD DO BASS.
FOR LIMóN -- FOR PEOPLE BUT WE
DO NEED A BAIL -- BECAUSE IT'S
STILL HAPPENING TODAY THANK YOU
[inaudible]
Q. [inaudible]
YES MA'AM -- HI MY NAME IS
CHRISTINE AND OF OUR AS AND I
WAS FORMALLY INCARCERATED.
I HAVE -- BEEN OUT FOR ABOUT A
LITTLE BIT OVER A MONTH.
MY INITIAL RELEASE DATE WAS JUNE
TWENTY SEVENTH BUT I RECEIVED AN
EARLY KICK OUT.
WITH NO PRIOR NOTICE THEY KIND
OF JUST YOU KNOW IN THE MIDDLE
OF THE NIGHT I THINK IT WAS THAT
AFTER -- EIGHT THEY JUST TOLD ME
TO ROLL IT UP THAT I WAS BEING
RELEASED -- I REMEMBER JUST
BEING NERVOUS BECAUSE I KNEW I
DIDN'T HAVE A PHONE IN MY
POSITION I DON'T HAVE ANY MONEY.
I DON'T HAVE A RIDE ADDING
CONTACTED ANYONE BUT WHILE BEING
INCARCERATED I READ MISPRINTS
BUCK.
AND I WROTE HER AND SHE WROTE ME
BACK AND PERSONALLY GAVE ME HER
PHONE NUMBER TO CALL HER
WHENEVER -- I WAS RELEASED AND
THAT SHE WOULD ACCEPT ME INTO
THE PROGRAM -- WHILE.
WAITING TO BE RELEASED THERE
ABOUT FIVE OR SIX OTHER GIRLS
ARE BEING RELEASED AROUND THE
SAME TIME.
NONE OF THEM ARE ANY OF US HAD A
PHONE AT THE TIME.
OR IN OUR POSSESSION. ONE OF THE
GIRLS -- OFFERED US TO GO OVER
TO OUR HOUSE WHICH WAS RIGHT
ACROSS THE STREET -- TO GO USE
THE PHONE AT OUR HOUSE.
BUT WHEN I HEARD THEM TALKING
ABOUT DRUGS AND ALCOHOL I
DECIDED TO STAY BACK AND I HAD
TO WAIT.
UNTIL SOMEBODY WALKED BY TO
ALLOW ME TO USE THE PHONE I
DON'T KNOW IF YOU GUYS ARE
FAMILIAR WITH -- THE LIN WOOD
AREA BUT LONG BEACH BOULEVARD IS
KNOWN FOR SOLICITING AND YOU
KNOW JUST ALL THE DANGER AROUND
THOSE AREAS SO I DON'T WANT TO
WALK DOWN THE STREET -- THANK
GOD I WAS ABLE TO FIND A PHONE.
AND CALLED IS FOR IN AT AROUND
NINE A LITTLE BIT OVER NINE AND
SHE ACTUALLY ANSWERED.
AND CONNECTED TO SOMEBODY I WAS
ABLE TO PICK ME UP -- AND GET ME
TO THE PROGRAM SAFE.
SO I JUST.
I'M THANKFUL THAT SHE WAS THERE
YOU KNOW THAT.
HELP WAS AVAILABLE BUT I'M LIKE
SHE SAID I FEEL LIKE JUST HAVING
PHONE CHARGING STATIONS OR THE
ABILITY FOR US TO MAKE PHONE
CALLS WITHOUT THEM HAVING TO BE
COLLIDE.
YOU KNOW OR EVEN TRANSPORTATION
TO SUMMER SAFER NOT LET US OUT
IN THE MIDDLE OF THE NIGHT.
SOMETHING SO SIMPLE CAN SAVE A
LIFE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT NAME AN
ORGANIZATION.
THANK YOU JESSICA BARTOLO WITH
THE WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY VERY PROUD TO SUPPORT
THE YOUNG ONE AND STRATUM CENTER.
NEW WAY OF LIFE AND THE SENATOR
IN THIS BILL.
THANK YOU -- OCCURS WITH
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIANS
SUPPORT.
MARGOT GEORGE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
KATHY SURE ACLU OF CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
SELENA PRIOR CALIFORNIA STATE
AND DOUBLE ACP IN SUPPORT.
ERIN HANEY CUT FIFTY IN SUPPORT.
JIM WEINBERG ON BEHALF OF THE
FRIENDS COMMITTEE ON LEGISLATION
CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON GOING BACK AS FOR
DRUG POLICY ALLIANCE AND THE
ELEVATOR CENTER FOR HUMAN RIGHTS
IN SUPPORT.
ROSE MARIE MENDEZ WITH TIME FOR
CHANGING IN SUPPORT.
THE PRAYER WILL SEND WHAT TIME
FOR CHANGE AND I SUPPORT.
ASHLEY CARTER ON BEHALF OF CUT
FIFTY IN STRONG SUPPORT.
GEN FOURTH WHEN WHEN THE NORTH
WIND LP IN SUPPORT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
PLEASE SHARE WITH THE TRANSLATE
THE NOT COALITION AND WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
KELLY LIEU DANS MORE WITH THE
TRANS GENDER GENDER VARIANT
INTERSEX JUSTICE PROJECT IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
IS THERE ANYONE IN OPPOSITION.
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN AS
CORSO'S ALONG BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION.
HERE IN OPPOSITION TO SB FORTY
TWO WE APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR --
TAKING AMENDMENTS IN THE FIRST
HOUSE -- DEALING WITH THE
TRANSPORTATION PROVISIONS OF THE
BILL -- WILL SPREE SHOULD THE
COMMITTEE'S EFFORTS TO NARROW
THE SCOPE OF THE BILL I EVEN
FURTHER HERE IN THIS COMMITTEE
OP WILL TELL YOU WE STILL HAVE
TO ANYTHING BIG OUTSTANDING
CONCERNS.
THE FIRST IS THAT EXISTING LAW
PROVIDES -- THE AUTHORITY FOR
SHERIFF -- RUNNING A JAIL TO
ALLOW A PROGRAM WHERE BY
SOMEBODY WHO DOES NOT WANT TO BE
RELEASED A CERTAIN TIME TO STAY
AN EXTRA -- SEVERAL HOURS IN
ORDER TO ACCOMMODATE THAT --
CHANGE UNTIL YOU GET TO A A
MORNING TIME OR SOME OTHER OF
POINT WHEN IT'S NOT -- AT NIGHT
TIME OR WHEN IT WHEN IT'S NOT
COLD OR SOMETHING LIKE THAT --
TO BE RELEASED AND SO THAT'S
EXISTING LAW THAT THAT MAY BE
OFFERED THIS WOULD MANDATE --
THAT THAT PROGRAM BE OFFERED --
IF A PERSON CHOOSES NOT TO AVAIL
THEMSELVES OF THAT OPTION THEN
THEY'RE REQUIRED TO BE OFFERED A
SAFE PLACE TO STAY SO PRESUMABLY
A NON CUSTODIAL ENVIRONMENT SO
EITHER -- CUSTODIAL OR NON
CUSTODIAL WAITING ROOM STILL IN
THE JAIL -- ONE OF THOSE OR BOTH
OF THOSE OPTIONS HAVE TO BE
PROVIDED UNDER THIS BILL -- SO
THAT CREATES OBVIOUSLY COST
PRESSURES AND MANDATES -- THE
SECOND PART OF THE BILL IS THE
REQUIREMENT THAT A PERSON WHO'S
BEEN IN CUSTODY FOR THIRTY DAYS
OR LONGER BE RELEASED WITH AT
LEAST THREE DAYS MEDICATION.
WE UNDERSTAND THE NEED AND
DESIRE FOR PEOPLE TO BE RELEASED
WITH MEDICINE IT'S NOT -- IN
OPPOSITION TO THAT THERE IS VERY
LITTLE LIMITATION EVEN WITH THE
BILL'S AMENDMENTS ARE ON WHAT
TYPES OF MEDICATIONS WOULD BE
RELEASED WITH THE PERSON -- THE
COULD BE MEDICINE THAT NEEDS TO
BE TAKEN UNDER SUPERVISION -- IT
COULD BE SOMETHING NECESSARY
LIKE INSULIN OR IT COULD BE AN
OPIATE -- ONE OF THOSE THINGS IS
EASILY ABUSED ONE OF THOSE IS
NOT -- SO I THINK THIS THERE
COULD BE GREATER SPECIFICITY AND
CLARITY ABOUT.
WHAT TYPES OF MEDICATIONS ARE
RELEASED?
AND WHETHER OR NOT IT'S A
PURPOSE BECAUSE UNFORTUNATELY
FOR BOTH OF THESE THINGS WE
THINK THEY BRING LIABILITY TO
COUNTIES.
IN AS MUCH AS THEY'D BE MANDATED
TO REQUIRE PEOPLE TO BE ALLOWED
TO STAY OR TO PROVIDE THEM WITH
MEDICATIONS AS THEY DEPART THE
FACILITY SO FOR THOSE REASONS
WERE OPPOSED TO THE BILL.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
ARE THERE ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION YES GOOD AFTERNOON
ELIZABETH ESPINOSA ON BEHALF OF
THE RURAL COUNTY REPRESENTATIVES
OF CALIFORNIA ALL ALIGN MY
COMMENTS WITH THOSE OF A MISTER
SELLS A LOT FROM THE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU -- ANY QUESTIONS FROM
COMMITTEE.
YES MISS WHAT -- FOR SOMEONE IT
THANK THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING
THE BILL I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT --
AND AND THANK YOU BOTH FOR YOUR
YOUR TESTIMONY HERE TODAY IT'S
VERY POWERFUL TO HEAR FROM YOU --
IT'S UNFORTUNATE THAT THE
TRAGEDY OF THE DEATH OF JUST ST
LOUIS IS WHAT HAS BEEN THE
CATALYST OF THIS -- BUT I'M
REALLY GLAD THAT YOU YOU BROUGHT
THIS TO US TODAY I'D LOVE TO BE
ADDED AS A CO AUTHOR AND WILL
CERTAINLY BE SUPPORTING THE BILL.
YES.
A MARKET OF I TO WANT TO THANK
SENATOR SCANNER -- FOR BRINGING
THIS BILL FORWARD AND ALSO WOULD --
BE HONORED TO JOIN ON AS A CO
AUTHOR -- AS A CHAIR OF THE
SELECT COMMITTEE ON INCARCERATED
WOMEN I ACTUALLY THINK THIS IS
AN ISSUE WORTH FURTHER
EXPLORATION IN THAT COMMITTEE SO
THAT WE CAN CONTINUE TO TALK
ABOUT AN UNVEILED.
I'M ALL OF THE TRAUMAS I MEAN
CHALLENGES THAT ARE FACED BY --
IN PARTICULAR WOMEN -- AND GIRLS
WHO ARE INCARCERATED -- I
ACTUALLY DON'T THINK THAT FOLKS
WHO ARE RELEASED WANT TO SPEND
ADDITIONAL TIME -- IN JAIL ARE
IN PRISON I THINK THEY WANT TO
GET OUT AS QUICKLY AS THEY CAN --
SPEAKING TO THE OPPOSITION BUT
IT'S MAKING SURE THAT -- THOSE
MEN AND WOMEN WHO ARE RELEASED
ARE RELEASED IN A WAY THAT IS
SAFE -- AND THAT BRINGS WITH THE
DIGNITY BECAUSE WHAT WE DON'T
WANT IS TO SEE FOLKS GOING IN OR
WE CERTAINLY DON'T WANT TO SEE
PEOPLE FURTHER ATTACKED OR EVEN
KILLED.
AND AS IT RELATES TO THE
MEDICATION I WAS THINKING
SPECIFICALLY AS IT RELATES TO
THE TESTIMONY OF OTHER WOMEN WHO
SHARED THAT IT WOULD ALSO BE
WONDERFUL TO MAKE SURE THAT
WOMEN ARE GIVEN I'M A COUPLE OF
DAYS WORTH OF PERSONAL HYGIENE
PRODUCTS.
YOU KNOW IT'S ONE THING TO HAVE
MEDICATION BUT IT'S SOMETHING
ELSE TO KIND OF HAVE SOME OF THE
PRODUCTS THAT YOU NEED AS YOU'RE
GOING OUT INTO THE WORLD AND
TRYING TO GET SETTLED.
SO I DON'T HAVE THAT MIGHT BE A
LITTLE TOO LATE TO PUT IN BUT I
WOULD HOPE THAT THAT WOULD BE
SOMETHING THAT COULD BE
CONSIDERED BECAUSE ULTIMATELY
THIS IS ABOUT.
YOU KNOW HOW WE TREAT ALL FOLKS
WITH DIGNITY.
THANK YOU HER ANY OTHER COMMENT
[inaudible]
YOU MAY.
YOU MAY CLOSE -- THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS AND I'M
HAPPY TO ADD TO REQUESTED CO
AUTHORS AND I FORGOT TO OPEN
WITH THAT I AM TAKING MIDIS.
TECHNICAL AND CLARIFYING
AMENDMENTS.
AND TO THE POINTER ON THE
MEDICATIONS THE LANGUAGE IN THE
BILL DOES SAY ESSENTIAL
MEDICATIONS -- SO I A AND IF WE
THINK ABOUT IT IF.
IF A PERSON FOR EXAMPLE IS
DIABETIC AND THEY ARE RELEASED
AT A TIME WHERE.
WE AND THEY HAVE NO BUT THAT YOU
KNOW THEY DIDN'T HAVE ON THEIR
PERSON THEIR PRESCRIPTION OR ANY
OF THAT.
THEN THEY REALLY DON'T HAVE THE
ABILITY TO IMMEDIATELY GET THAT
ESSENTIAL MEDICATION THAT THEY
NEED SO I THINK THAT'S VERY --
NECESSARY AND IN TERMS OF THE
THAT IT ISN'T STATUTE ALREADY
FOR JAILS TO BE ABLE TO OFFER TO
A PERSON.
THAT YOU KNOW THEY COULD BE
RELEASED AT A DIFFERENT TIME --
IF WE TAKE THE OUR TESTIMONY FOR
MISS NAVARRO'S SHE WASN'T MAY
DATE WASN'T GIVEN THAT OFFER --
AND SO IT'S MAYBE THERE ARE SOME
OF OUR COUNTY JAILS THAT ARE
AVAILING -- THERE -- FOLKS OF
THAT BUT IT'S NOT WELL KNOWN AND
IT'S NOT AS FAR AS WE COULD --
GET INFORMATION ON BEING
UTILIZED AND THEN THE LAST THING
THAT LAST POINT I'D MAKE AND I
AM REALLY REALLY AM PROUD OF
MISSING OF OURS.
FOR HAVING THE GOOD SENSE NUMBER
ONE NOT GO WITH THE OTHER WOMEN
WHO WERE RELEASED -- TO WHERE
SHE MIGHT BE.
EXPOSED TO DRUGS AND WHETHER SHE
USE THEM HERSELF FOR NOT SHE
COULD HAVE BEEN AND SUBJECT TO
ARREST AGAIN.
OR IT -- IT IT IN THE CASE OF
MANY OTHER PEOPLE UNFORTUNATELY
THEY IMMEDIATELY EXPERIENCE AN
OVERDOSE BECAUSE THEY'VE NOT HAD.
DRUGS IN THE NAY OR IMMEDIATELY --
GIVEN THEM BUT SHE HAD THE GOOD
SENSE NOT TO DO THAT AND YET
JUST HOW WHAT A KIND OF MIRACLE
THAT SHE HAPPENED TO READ MISTER
BURTON'S BOOK AND CONTACTED MS
BURTON AND HAD SOMEONE THAT
WOULD COME AND PICK HER UP.
THAT IS A RARE THING TO HAVE
HAPPEN AND IF YOU THINK ABOUT
WHERE OUR JAILS ARE SITUATED
BELIEVE ME.
ANYONE HANG AROUND OUR JAILS IN
THE MIDDLE OF THE NIGHT IS NOT
HANG AROUND FOR A GOOD PERSON
COULD PURPOSE THEY'RE USUALLY
PREDATORY INDIVIDUALS WHETHER
THEY'RE ENGAGED IN HUMAN
TRAFFICKING OR WHETHER THEY'RE
ENGAGED IN DRUG DEALING OR ANY
NUMBER OF OTHER THINGS.
THOSE ARE THE TYPE OF PEOPLE
THAT HANG AROUND JAILS SO THE
ONE OF THE OWNER OF A PERSON IS
RELEASED THAT PERSON IS
IMMEDIATELY PUT AT RISK.
SO I THINK THIS BILL MAKES A LOT
OF SENSE I APPRECIATE -- BEING
ABLE TO PRESENT IT TO ACCEPT THE
COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS WITH THAT
I ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
IN THANK YOU AND I AND I HOPE.
THAT -- THE SHERIFF IN THE RURAL
COUNTIES WILL WORK WITH.
WITH THE AUTHOR -- AND MAYBE
NINETY NINE POINT 99% OF THE
DETAILS DO.
OFFER AND MAKE SURE THAT THEY
DON'T PUT PEOPLE OUT INCLEMENT
WEATHER AND THINGS THAT NATURE
BUT IT ONLY TAKES ONE AND
HOPEFULLY YOU LOOK AT THIS I
KNOW WE USE MAY VERSUS SHALL.
AND I THINK.
IF YOU'RE DOING IT ALREADY.
DAN SHALL IS NOT GOING TO BE A
PROBLEM.
IN PART TWO I AM THE INSULIN I I
UNDERSTAND.
BUT ALSO THE LOOK I I I SEE A
LOT OF HOMELESS PEOPLE.
IN LOS ANGELES.
MANY OF THEM I BELIEVE DO NEED
PSYCHOTROPIC SOME OF THEM DIDN'T
GET IT WHEN THEY LEFT PRISON
THEY HAD IT WHEN THEY WERE IN
PRISON.
AND SO I'M NOT.
TOO UPSET IF YOU DON'T GIVE THEM
MUST ENOUGH SUPPLIES SO THAT
THEY CAN DEAL WITH REALITY WHEN
THEY GET OUT OTHERWISE HE MAY
END UP IN.
BEING HOMELESS AND OTHER THINGS
AND SO -- OBVIOUSLY WE'RE GONNA
MAKE SURE ADDITIONAL LIABILITIES
OR OTHER ROLE COUNTIES.
URBAN COUNTIES OR ANYTHING.
OF THAT NATURE BUT IN SOME CASES
SOME PEOPLE MAY NEED.
SOME OF THOSE DRUGS JUST TO BE
ABLE TO GET THROUGH THE DAY WHEN
THEY GET OUT -- AND SO -- WITH
THAT CHEERS RECOMMEND IN I ON SB
FORTY TWO THE MOTION IS TO PASS
AS AMENDED TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE JONES SAWYER.
GEN SIR IRAQI [inaudible]
BARRICADE HAND [inaudible]
MATHIS.
MATHIS NOT VOTING KAMLAGER-DOVE.
KAMLAGER-DOVE I QUIRK
[inaudible]
SANTIAGO.
WICKS WICKS I IMAGES ON CALL.
VOTE.
AND WE NEED TO MORE THREE
MEMBERS ARE OUT DURING THE AND
YOUR NEXT.
ONE THANK YOU.
SO -- THANK YOU I'M COMMITTEE
MEMBERS AND A CHAIR WE WILL --
PERCENT NOW I WILL SB THREE
NINETY FOUR WHAT SB THREE NINETY
FOR THE PURPOSE OF IT IS REALLY
IF WE HAVE THE ABILITY TO KEEP A
FAMILY INTACT.
THEN I THINK THERE'S SO MANY --
SO MANY -- IT.
PUBLIC SAFETY COMMUNITY SAFETY
WELL BEING PUBLIC HEALTH --
REASONS TO DO OUR BEST TO KEEP
FAMILIES INTACT -- AND SO WHAT
THIS BILL WOULD DO IS IT WOULD
OFFER [inaudible]
THE IT WOULD CREATE A DIVERSION
COURT FOR PRIMARY CARE GIVERS TO
PROVIDE OPTION FOR PEOPLE WITH
DEPENDENTS NO ONLY SAY PEOPLE
DEPENDENCY DOES NOT ONLY HAVE TO
BE A PERSON WITH CHILDREN.
IT CAN BE A PERSON WHO IS THE
PRIMARY CARETAKER SAY OF AN
ELDERLY PARENT OR SOMEONE ELSE.
AND IF THEY ARE.
INSTEAD INCARCERATED THEN THE
PEOPLE THAT ARE DEPENDENT ON
THEM IN THE CASE OF CHILDREN ARE
OFTEN PUT IN OUR FOSTER SYSTEM
AND WE KNOW THE OUTCOMES FOR OUR
FOSTER CHILDREN IS NOT ARE NOT
GREAT -- BUT WE ALSO KNOW THAT
OTHER PEOPLE DEPENDENT ON THAT
THEIR CARE GIVER IS REMOVED
THERE THAT HAS SERIOUS
IMPLICATIONS. FOR THOSE PEOPLE
AND THEN ADDITIONALLY.
THERE'S ECONOMIC IMPACTS ON
EVERY PART OF THE FAMILY -- SO
THERE'S MANY THINGS IN THE BILL
THAT -- LIMIT WHO WOULD BE ABLE
TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THIS
THERE'S JUDICIAL DISCRETION BUT
WHAT IT DOES IS CREATE THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR PRE TRIAL
DIVERSION FOR THOSE PEOPLE WHO
WOULD QUALIFY. TO BE ABLE TO
KEEP FAMILIES TOGETHER AND WITH
THAT I WOULD LIKE MY WITNESSES --
TO TO TESTIFY THANK YOU THANK
YOU SO MUCH.
I KNOW THAT MEMBERS OF TODAY'S
COMMITTEE OUR PARENTS -- I'M
SORRY MY NAME IS ASHLEY CARTER
I'M FORMERLY INCARCERATED WOMAN.
I KNOW THAT SOME OF YOU ARE
PARENTS.
AS PARENTS I'M SURE YOU CAN
AGREE THAT THERE'S ALMOST NO
PAIN GREATER THAN THAT OF SEEING
YOUR CHILD SUFFER AND NOT BE
ABLE TO HELP.
MY LIFE UP UNTIL I FOUND OUT
THAT I WAS GOING TO BE A MOTHER
WAS CHAOTIC AT BEST.
FULL OF POVERTY PAIN ABUSE AND
ABANDONMENT.
MY DAUGHTER LITERALLY SAVED ME
FROM THAT LIFE.
FROM THE MOMENT THAT I FOUND OUT
I WAS PREGNANT.
I COMPLETELY COMMITTED MYSELF TO
CREATING THE BEST LIFE POSSIBLE
FOR HER.
UNFORTUNATELY I FAILED IN DOING
SO.
THE DECISIONS A MISTAKE THAT I
HAD MADEUP UNTIL THAT POINT HAD
CAUGHT UP TO ME AND I WAS
INDICTED ON DRUG CHARGES WHEN MY
DAUGHTER WAS JUST EIGHT MONTHS
OLD.
I SPENT THE FOLLOWING THREE
YEARS FIGHTING TO PROVE TO THE
COURTS MY COMMUNITY AND TO
MYSELF.
THAT I WAS MORE THAN JUST MY
MISTAKES.
I WORK TWO JOBS BECAME A
CELEBRATED EMPLOYEE AND ROLLED
IN SCHOOL ACTIVELY PARTICIPATED
IN GIVING BACK TO MY COMMUNITY
TO ORGANIZING DRIVES AND RAISING
MONEY FOR LOCAL CAUSES.
I ATTENDED THERAPY REGULARLY
COMPLIED WITH EVERY SINGLE
STIPULATION THAT PROBATION AND
PRETRIAL SET FORTH BEFORE MEET
WITH NOT ONE SINGLE VIOLATION.
THIRTY DRUG TEST OR SO MUCH AS A
TRAFFIC TICKET IN THREE YEARS.
WHEN I WENT BEFORE THE JUDGE FOR
SENTENCING AND ASKED THAT HE
TAKE INTO ACCOUNT MY EFFORTS AND
PROVEN CHANGE OVER THE PAST
THREE YEARS?
I WAS TOLD THAT WHILE ALL THAT
WAS GREAT I HAD TO PAY.
THE REALITY OF HIS STATEMENT WAS
THAT MY DAUGHTER HAD TO PAY.
MY MOTHER HAD TO PAY AND I WOULD
NEVER BE DONE PAYING.
MY YOUNGEST DAUGHTER O'MARA WHO
WAS JUST SITTING ON MY LAP.
IS HERE WITH ME.
AND SHE IS EXACTLY HOW OLD MY
DAUGHTER ASIA WAS WHEN I KISSED
HER GOODBYE AT THE PRISON GATES
I WOULDN'T SEE HER AGAIN FOR THE
NEXT FOUR YEARS.
THE AFFECTS OF MY INCARCERATION
HAVE HAD RIPPLES FAR GREATER
THAN WHAT MOST PEOPLE.
WHO HAVE NEVER ENCOUNTERED
INCARCERATION CAM REALIZE?
AND THE REALITY IS THAT MOST OF
THE CONSEQUENCES OF
INCARCERATION LAND ON OUR BABIES.
THIS NEEDS TO CHANGE SB THREE
NINETY FOUR IS THE MECHANISM FOR
THAT CHANGE.
NOT BY ALLOWING MOTHERS AND
FATHERS TO GET OFF SCOT FREE BUT
BY AFFORDING THEM THE
OPPORTUNITY TO RECEIVE THE
SUPPORT AND RESOURCES THAT THEY
SO DESPERATELY NEED.
IN ORDER TO DO BETTER AND BE
BETTER FOR THEMSELVES THEIR
CHILDREN IN OUR SOCIETY.
SB THREE NINETY FOUR IS NOT A
SECOND CHANCE FOR MOST OF US IS
THE FIRST THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
IN A WAY WHAT REMAINED AS A TIME
FOR CHANGE -- I LOST MY KIDS
ABOUT FIVE YEARS AGO WHEN I WAS
AT FIRST INCARCERATED AND DOES
THE FIRST AND LAST TIME I WAS
INCARCERATED -- IN THOSE FIVE
YEARS -- TRYING TO REGAIN THAT
RELATIONSHIP WITH THEM.
AFTER THE FIRST THREE YEARS THAT
THEY WERE GONE FOR ME HI -- WHAT
WAS IT WAS STRANGE?
IT WAS A STRAINED RELATIONSHIP --
TWO YEARS AGO I PHYSICALLY LOST
THEM I LOST CUSTODY OF THEM AND
THEY WENT INTO THE FOSTER SYSTEM --
SINCE THEN I'VE GOTTEN MY SON
BACK AND BUT A YEAR ABOUT
SIXTEEN MONTHS AFTER THAT I GOT
MY DAUGHTER BACK.
AND I'M TRYING TO REGAIN MY
RELATIONSHIP WITH HER I DON'T I
DON'T KNOW WHO SHE IS AND SHE
DOESN'T KNOW I AM.
I'M WITH THE TIME FOR CHANGE
FOUNDATION HERE AND WHAT THE
TIME FOR CHANGE FOUNDATION
PROGRAM DOES IS GIVE ME THE
SUPPORT.
THE THE GROUPS THE IT GIVES ME
THE SUPPORT THAT I NEED IN ORDER
TO BE A BETTER BETTER MOTHER FOR
MY CHILDREN.
SB OF NINE SB NINETY FOUR WERE
NOT ONLY HELP ME AND HELP
MOTHERS LIKE ME BUT WOULD HELP
THE NEXT OF KIN.
WITH THINGS THE WITH.
THE THINGS THAT I NEEDED HELP
WITH I HAD NOBODY TO HELP ME.
HAD THERE BEEN SOMETHING LIKE
THIS.
I WOULDN'T HAVE STRANGERS IN MY
HOME LIVING WITH ME NOW TRYING
TO REGAIN MY RELATIONSHIP WITH
MY KIDS.
THANK YOU THANK YOU. FOR ANY
OTHER.
ARE THERE ANY OTHER.
NAME AN ORGANIZATION.
MICHAEL MENDOZA WITH THE
INTERESTS OF THOSE COALITION IS
STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU SIR -- HAIRS WITH
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIANS
SUPPORT.
KATHY HALL WITH THE CALIFORNIA
STATE PTA IN SUPPORT.
JIM LIMBURGER ON BEHALF OF THE
FRIENDS COMMITTEE ON LEGISLATION
TO CALIFORNIA AND STRONG SUPPORT.
MARGOT GEORGIA MAY HAVE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT.
ELIZABETH ASPEN US ON BEHALF OF
THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS AND SUPPORT EACH.
I MEAN RENTAL AMERICAN ACADEMY
OF PEDIATRICS CALIFORNIA IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
THE CREW WILL SO IT'S TIME FOR
CHANGE FOUNDATION STRONGLY
SUPPORT.
SUSAN BURDEN IN THE WAY OF LIFE
IN STRONG SUPPORT.
KIM CARTER FOUNDER AND A ****
CONTI CHANGED FOUNDATION AND I
STRONGLY ARGUE AND SUPPORT
KEEPING FAMILIES HOW THANK YOU
YOU WILL. TO A BRIEF DIMMING AS
AND SUPPORT FROM CUT
[inaudible]
FIFTY THANK YOU.
GOING BACK IS FOR DRUG POLICY
ALLIANCE IN THE ELEVATOR CENTER
FOR HUMAN RIGHTS IN SUPPORT.
LOGIN CAMP WITH THE JEWISH
COUNCIL CALIFORNIA-- WE DON'T
HAVE A POSITION ON THE BILL BUT
WE HAVE BEEN WORKING WITH
AUTHORS OFFICE -- BRINGING IT IN
LINE WITH OTHER DIVERSION
PROGRAMS AND OTHER TECHNICAL
AMENDMENTS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
ANY QUESTIONS.
COMMENT.
YES THIS WORKS.
I WON IT AGAIN THANK THE AUTHOR
PUT BRING THIS BILL FORWARD AND
REALLY APPRECIATE GIRLS
TESTIMONY IN THIS AND AS A
MOTHER OF A TWO YEAR OLD.
I KNOW HOW POWERFUL THAT
CONNECTION TO YOUR CHILD IS AND
HOW IMPORTANT IT CONNECTION IS
TO YOUR REHABILITATION AS WELL --
SO AM VERY APPRECIATIVE IN
SUPPORT OF AND WANT TO ADD ON AS
A CO AUTHOR AS WELL.
I APOLOGIZE TO PROVIDE DANCE IS
THERE ANY OPPOSITION.
MR SELF SAITO'S ON HIS WAY ALONG
WITH THE DA SO COULD YOU MAKE
ROOM.
I APOLOGIZE TO YOU GENTLEMAN.
THE AFTERNOON I'M MOVING TO FAST.
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS
LARRY MORSE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA DISTRICT ATTORNEYS
ASSOCIATION WE REMAIN
REGRETTABLY OPPOSED. TO SB THREE
NINETY FOUR WE HAVE SEVERAL
CONCERNS WITH THE BILL.
MOST IMPORTANTLY WALL CASE LAW
HAS NOT DRAWN THIS LINE IN THE
SAND IS THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS
NOTES WE BELIEVE SB THREE NINETY
FOUR IS NOT.
CONSISTENT WITH WHAT WITH WHAT
MOST OF US UNDERSTAND THIS EQUAL
PROTECTION UNDER THE LAW.
THIS BILL WOULD ALLOW THE
CREATION OF A NEW PRE TRIAL
DIVERSION SCHEME SINGLING OUT
ONE CLASS OF INDIVIDUALS.
PARENTS OF CHILDREN UNDER
EIGHTEEN FOR MORE FAVORABLE
TREATMENT UNDER THE LAW.
THAN OTHERS CHARGED WITH SIMILAR
CRIMES.
UNDER SB THREE NINETY FOUR
DEFENDANT CHARGED WITH ALMOST
ANY MISDEMEANOR INCLUDING
MISDEMEANORS SEX OFFENSES OR ANY
NON SERIOUS NON VIOLENT FELONY.
INCLUDING THEFT FRAUD AND
BURGLARY WOULD BE ELIGIBLE FOR A
DIVERSION PROGRAM OF UNSPECIFIED
LENGTH.
IF HERE SHE CAN SHOW THAT HERE
SHE IS THE PRIMARY CARE GIVER OF
ANY CHILD UNDER THE AGE OF
EIGHTEEN INDEED IF A DEFENDANT
IS IN A TWO PARENT HOME WHERE
ONE PARENT IS A PRIMARY CARE
GIVER IN TERMS OF PHYSICAL.
AND EMOTIONAL SUPPORT AND THE
OTHER PARENT IS THE FINANCIAL
SUPPORT IT APPEARS THAT BOTH
WOULD BE ELIGIBLE FOR DIVERSION
UNDER THIS BILL.
THIS BILL ALSO OFFENDS NOTIONS
OF EQUAL PROTECTION BY
BENEFITING WEALTHIER DEFENDANTS
WHO WERE ABLE TO PAY FOR THE
COST OF THESE DIVERSION PROGRAMS.
THE BILL DOES NOT PROPOSE ANY
KIND OF FUNDING STREAM TO PAY
THE CONSIDERABLE COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH THIS DIVERSION
PROGRAM.
SO THOSE DEFENDANTS WITH THE
MEANS TO PAY FOR IT THEMSELVES
WILL HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
HAVE CRIMES ARE RACED.
BUT OTHER DEFENDANTS WITHOUT
CHILDREN UNDER EIGHTEEN WILL
HAVE ON THEIR RECORDS.
WELL NOT SPEAKING FOR LA COUNTY
IT'S WORTH NOTING THAT IN LA
COUNTY ALONE THERE ARE ROUGHLY A
QUARTER MILLION MISDEMEANORS
FILED EACH YEAR.
SB THREE NINETY FOUR WOULD ALLOW
MANY OF THESE DEFENDANTS PLUS A
SUBSTANTIAL NUMBER OF ELEVEN
SEVENTY H. FELONS TO MAKE A CASE
FOR DIVERSION BASED SOLELY ON
THE FACT THAT THEY HAVE CHILDREN.
LEAVING THOSE WHO DON'T HAVE
CHILDREN NO OPPORTUNITY TO BE
DIVERTED FOR THE SAME CRIMES.
NOT ONLY IS THIS INEQUITABLE IT
IS GUARANTEED TO BOG DOWN THE
ADMINISTRATION OF JUSTICE.
SINCE THIS IS A PRE PLEA PROGRAM
THE COURT WOULD HAVE TO LEAVE
ALL OF THESE CASES OPEN FOR UP
TO TWO YEARS WHILE THE DEFENDANT
PARTICIPATES IN THE PROGRAM.
SAY HOWEVER THAT THE DEFENDANT
FAILS THE PROGRAM AFTER EIGHTEEN
MONTHS PROSECUTORS WOULD THEN BE
SCRAMBLING TO PUT TOGETHER A
CASE ON THE ORIGINAL CHARGES
WERE WITNESSES MAY LOOK NO
LONGER BE AVAILABLE OR MEMORIES
OF DEM.
SB THREE NINETY FOUR ALSO FAILS
TO EVEN CONSIDER THE VICTIMS OF
THESE CRIMES MANY OF WHOM WERE
ENTITLED TO RESTITUTION.
HOW AND WHEN ILL RESTITUTION BE
PAID WHILE THE CASE IS BEING
DIVERTED?
CONSIDER TOO THAT SINCE A PERSON
WHO COMPLETES A PRETRIAL
DIVERSION PROGRAM WOULD HAVE THE
CRIME OR RAISED A FUTURE
EMPLOYER WILL NOT BE ALERTED TO
THE FACT THAT A NEW EMPLOYEE.
AND TRUSTED WITH HANDLING MONEY
OR FINANCIAL RESPONSIBILITIES
MAY HAVE MULTIPLE ARRESTS FOR
FORGERY EMBEZZLEMENT OR OTHER
FINANCIAL CRIMES.
D. A.'S ACROSS CALIFORNIA HAVE
ENTHUSIASTICALLY ESTABLISH MANY
DIVERSION PROGRAMS IN THEIR
COUNTIES FOR SUBSTANCE ABUSE
MENTAL HEALTH VETERANS AND
HOMELESSNESS JUST TO NAME A FEW.
HOWEVER THIS BILL IF PASSED INTO
LAW WILL LIKELY NOT BE
IMPLEMENTED BY MANY D. A.'S A
FACT THAT SEEMS CURIOUSLY AT
ODDS WITH ITS INTENT.
THE BILL PROVIDES THAT THE COURT
MAY SET UP THE FORMAL PRE TRIAL
DIVERSION PROGRAM OUTLINED HERE
WITH THE CONCURRENCE OF THE DA
AND THE PUBLIC DEFENDER.
IT DOES NOT REQUIRE A DA TO
PARTICIPATE IN THE CREATION OF
SUCH A PROGRAM AND NO SUCH
PROGRAM CAN BE CREATED WITH OUT
THE PARTICIPATION OF THE DA.
AND SINCE THE BILL ALLOWS A
JUDGE TO ENROLL A DEFENDANT IN
THE PROGRAM OVER THE AND JOB
OBJECTIONS OF THE DA.
IT IS VERY LIKELY THAT MOST DA
SIMPLY WON'T CREATE THESE
PROGRAMS BECAUSE THEY WILL NOT
WISH TO BE FORCED TO DIVERT
DEFENDANTS THEY BELIEVE TO BE
UNDESERVING.
OF HAVING THEIR CRIMES ARE
RAISED.
WE BELIEVE THIS BILL IS
INEQUITABLE ARBITRARY AND COSTLY
AND WE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
OVER.
THE TIME.
BETWEEN YOU ALSO WANT YOU
[inaudible]
SORRY -- USE FAR LESS NOT I
THINK THANK YOU.
MANAGER MEMBERS COREY CELLS --
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION OUR
POSITION IS OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED -- THE MINUTE THAT WE
HAVE SUGGESTED IS THAT A PERSON
WHO -- IS ALLEGED TO HAVE
COMMITTED A CRIME AGAINST.
THE CHILD OR THE PERSON WITH
WHOM.
THE DEFENDANT IS.
TRYING TO BE PLACED BACK WITHIN
THE HOME.
THAT AS WE UNDERSTAND THE THE
THE PURPOSE OF THE BILL THAT IF
THAT IF THE CRIME IS AGAINST
THAT PERSON THAT THEY WOULD NOT
THE THE WOULD BE EXCLUDED FROM
BEING DIVERTED UNDER THIS BILL --
SO WE'VE BEEN WORKING WITH THE
AUTHOR AND STAFF ON TRYING TO
COME TOGETHER WE'VE RECOMMENDED
LANGUAGE THAT WOULD ACHIEVE THAT
AGAIN -- IT'S JUST I THINK THAT
THAT CLEAR SPECIFICATION THAT
WHILE DIVERSION MAY BE
APPROPRIATE IN CERTAIN
CIRCUMSTANCES WE BELIEVE THAT
IT'S NOT APPROPRIATE WHEN THE
VICTIM OF THAT THE ALLEGED
VICTIM OF THE CRIME.
IS THE PERSON WHO IS SOUGHT TO
BE RECONNECTED WITH THE
DEFENDANT SO THAT'S OUR THAT'S
OUR POSITION AND WE ASK FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANY OTHERS IN
OPPOSITION.
STEPHANIE MANN CHAIR MEMBERS RAN
SHERMAN WITH THE RIVERSIDE
SHERIFF'S ASSOCIATION IN
OPPOSITION.
IN SUPPORT APOLOGIES MISS THE
WINDOW -- RISK INVOLVED WITH THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS THANK YOU.
OKAY I'D LIKE TO BRING IT BACK
TO THE DíAS IF THERE ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
MRS SB.
THREE NINE FOUR I TO WHAT I HAVE
A QUESTION OF CLARIFICATION THIS --
IS ONLY FOR MISDEMEANORS AND NON
VIOLENT FELONIES CORRECT.
CORRECT [inaudible]
THERE.
WE HAVE A MOTION.
ON SB THREE NINETY FOR THE
MOTION IS TO PASS JONES SAWYER
[inaudible]
LACKEY.
BARRICADE HAN BARRICADE HAD AYE
MATHIS.
MATHIS NOT VOTING KAMLAGER-DOVE.
KAMLAGER-DOVE I QUIRK
[inaudible]
I SANTIAGO.
WICKS WICKS I MANAGER TERRY
COULD I ADD ON TO THE OTHER
BILLS AND I'M GOING TO HAVE TO
LEAVE HIS OR ANY OF THE BILL
THAT'S BEEN HEARD [inaudible]
THIS AFTERNOON [inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
SO I'M.
AS WITH THE ONE WE JUST HEARD SB
THREE NINE FOUR HAS FOUR VOTES
WE'RE GONNA KEEP THAT ON CALL.
YOU NEED ONE MORE.
THANK YOU SO NOW WE'RE GONNA DO
ADD ONS FOR S. B.. FORTY FORTY
TWO FOR THE ABSENT MEMBERS WHO
JUST RETURNED.
ON SB FORTY TWO POWER QUE HAN.
BARRICADE HANNAH I QUIRK.
QUIRK I THANK YOU THAT MEASURE
PASSES THANK YOU SENATOR SKINNER
WILL KEEP YOU APPRISED.
SO.
WE ARE WAITING FOR A FEW MORE
FOLKS WERE WAITING FOR SENATOR
WIENER.
THAT'S IT.
FOR OKAY THAT'S IT.
IS HE COMING -- AND WHAT ABOUT
NIELSEN. TWO FIVE NINE SO HAS
SOMEONE CALLED HIM YEAH
[inaudible]
YES.
WE CAN DO ADD ONS FOR ALL OF THE
BILLS THAT WERE HEARD EARLIER
TODAY WHILE WE'RE WAITING FOR
SENATORS.
WIENER.
ON SB TWENTY THREE THIS MEASURE
WAS ON CALL BARRICADE HAN.
BARRICADE HAD I AM AT YOUR PATH
.
SO AS WE WANT.
SB.
ONE THREE TWO WE WILL NOW HEAR
SB ONE THREE TWO SENATOR WINNERS
HERE.
GREAT THANK YOU SOME REMEMBER --
SP ONE THIRTY TWO DRESSES A VERY
REAL PROBLEM FACING INCARCERATED --
TRANSGENDER INDIVIDUALS ARE
SPECIFICALLY -- I'D TRANSGENDER
PEOPLE.
WERE BEING HOUSED IN CDC R..
ACCORDING TO THEIR SEX ASSIGNED
AT BIRTH -- AS OPPOSED TO THEIR
OWN OUR PERCEPTION OF SAFETY --
OR THEIR GENDER IDENTITY -- AND
THIS MISS CLASSIFICATION --
RESULTS AND SIGNIFICANT RISK OF
OF VIOLENCE AND FOR EXAMPLE A
TRANSGENDER WOMEN WHO ARE OF
HOUSE -- OVER THEIR OBJECTION --
IN MAIL FACILITIES THAT ARE THEN --
VICTIMIZED AND THEN A TIMES
PLACE IN ISOLATION QUOTE ON
QUOTE FOR THEIR OWN PROTECTION --
AND SO ON SB ONE THIRTY TO SIX
TO ADDRESS -- THIS -- PROBLEM --
BY ENSURING THAT TRANSGENDER
PEOPLE WHO ARE INCARCERATED ARE
TREATED WITH -- BASIC THING ANY --
SO THAT THERE ARE HEALTH AND
SAFETY IS RESPECTED AND THEIR
GENDER IDENTITY.
HI IS RESPECTED -- SO THE BILL
WILL REQUIRE THAT DURING THE
INITIAL INTAKE PROCESS AT CDC
ARE.
A RECORD OF THE INDIVIDUALS --
AJ SELF REPORTED GENDER IDENTITY --
PREFERRED FIRST NAME AND
PRONOUNS AND HONORIFICS -- AND
THE PREFERRED GENDER IDENTITY OF
IT ANY OFFICER WHO WOULD CONDUCT
A BODY SEARCH OF THAT INDIVIDUAL --
REQUIRES STAFF AND CONTRACTORS
OF CDC ARE TO CONSISTENTLY USE --
THE GENDER OF PRONOUN HONORIFIC
AND NAMED SPECIFIED BY THE
INDIVIDUAL AND VERBAL AND
WRITTEN COMMUNICATIONS -- IT
WILL REQUIRE CDC ARE TO HELL'S
OF TRANSGENDER INDIVIDUAL AT A
CORRECTIONAL FACILITY DESIGNATED
FOR MEN OR WOMEN.
ACCORDING TO THAT PERSON'S OWN
PERCEPTION OF THE FACILITY THAT
WOULD BE SAFEST FOR THEM ROLL
TURNITIN BILLY THEIR GENDER
IDENTITY ABOUT IS THE SAFEST.
IT WILL REQUIRE CDC ARE TO
ASSIGN HOUSING PLACEMENT WITH IN
A CORRECTIONAL FACILITY.
ACCORDING TO A TRANSGENDER
PERSONS SENSE OF HEALTH AND
SAFETY -- WHICH INCLUDES THE
GENDER POPULATION OF THE
FACILITY AND ALSO THE TYPE OF
HOUSING UNIT.
I HOWEVER OF CDC ARE HAS
SPECIFIC SECURITY OR MANAGEMENT
CONCERNS SB ONE THIRTY TWO DOES
ALLOW TO SEE OUR FLEXIBILITY TO
OVERRIDE THE PLACEMENT WITHIN
THE FACILITY -- AT WHICH THE
PERSON HAS BEEN ASSIGNED -- WE
KNOW THAT ALMOST 40% OF
TRANSGENDER INDIVIDUALS -- WHO
ARE INCARCERATED OUR REPORT --
EXPERIENCING SEXUAL
VICTIMIZATION COMPARED TO JUST
4% OF THE OVERALL OUR POPULATION.
I IN CALIFORNIA A STUDY OF THE
STATE'S PRISON ARE DESIGNATED
FOR MEN FOUND THAT THE RATE OF
SEXUAL ASSAULT FOR TRANSGENDER
WOMEN IN THOSE PRISONS -- WAS
THIRTEEN TIMES HIGHER THAN FOR
MEN IN THE SAME PRESENCE -- TO
HOUSE TRANSGENDER PEOPLE IN
FACILITIES THAT DO NOT
CORRESPOND WITH THEIR PERCEPTION
OF THEIR OWN SAFETY OR THEIR
GENDER IDENTITY.
UP THESE INDIVIDUALS AT
SIGNIFICANT RISK OF PHYSICAL
ASSAULT AND SEXUAL VICTIMIZATION --
AND ALSO REDUCES THEIR ACCESS TO
REHABILITATIVE PROGRAMS.
SB ONE THIRTY TWO CONTINUES --
AND WILL WE HOPE PUT AN END --
OR GET US TO THE END OF A
PROCESS -- WE'RE WE TREAT
TRANSGENDER INCARCERATED PEOPLE
OF WITH THE DIGNITY AND RESPECT --
THEY DESERVE -- WITH ME TODAY TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
OR CASEY MATTHEWS -- FROM TGI
JUSTICE PROJECT.
I KELLY LIEU DANS MAURER FROM
THE TO JUDGE JUSTICE PROJECT --
AND MACHE POLITO FROM THE TRANS
LET'S YOU KNOW COALITION.
YOU ALL HAVE. FIVE MINUTES.
LONG.
THE PRESIDENT DIVIDE IT UP.
OKAY.
GOOD EVENING EVERYBODY.
I'M HONORED TO BE HERE.
TODAY THANK YOU -- I'M HERE
TODAY TO TESTIFY ON SENATE BILL
ONE THIRTY TWO AS A RECENTLY
INCARCERATED.
TRANS MAN OF EXPERIENCE SENATE
BILL ONE THIRTY TWO WOULD HAVE
TOLD ME A LOT AND CAN STILL HELP
OTHER TRANS INCARCERATED PEOPLE
FOR ME BI AND TRANS IN A WOMEN'S
PRISON WITH A FACE FULL OF
FACIAL HAIR.
I WAS ABLE TO MOVE ENTIRE A
MOVING TARGET FOR HARASSMENT
FROM STAFF OFTEN TELL BILLY
DEMEAN AND TERRORIZED BY SOME OF
THE STAFF WHO THOUGHT I WAS A
TOPIC OF THEIR LIVES.
I WAS THE INMATE WHO ALWAYS
TAPED OVER MY FIRST NAME ON MY
CDC OUR ID SOME STAFF WILL MAKE
IT A POINT TO CALL ME MISS OUR
MA'AM.
I'D EXCEPT THE VERBAL ABUSE
EVERY TIME BECAUSE I DIDN'T WANT
TO WRITE A WHICH WOULD KEEP ME
INCARCERATED LONGER.
SO I WOULD COVER MY FIRST NAME
IN HOPES THAT THEY WOULD JUST
CALL ME BY MY LAST NAME.
AND DOING THIS I RISK IN A RIDE
UP FORTY FACE ESTATE PROPERTY.
BUT PAN INTENTIONALLY MISS
GENDERED EVERY DAY WAS
UNBEARABLE WITH THIS BILL CDC
ARE OFFICIALS WILL BE REQUIRED
TO USE THE PROPER NAME PRONOUNS
AND HORRIFIC.
WHICH WILL BETTER SUPPORT TRANS
PEOPLE TRYING TO SURVIVE IN THE
PRISON SYSTEM.
AS FOR THE ASK FOR THE AS FOR
THE THE NEXT PART OF THIS BILL
THAT ADDRESSES HOUSE AND I
BELIEVE EVERY TRANS PERSON
SHOULD BE ABLE TO CHOOSE WHERE
THEY FEEL SAFE IS.
MY TRANCE MY TRASH GENDERS
SISTER'S FACE A LOT OF PHYSICAL
AND EMOTIONAL DANGER A MAN'S
PRESENT F. SB ONE THIRTY TWO
WILL ALLOW EVERY TRANSPERSONAL
OF EXPERIENCE THAT IS
INCARCERATED TO BE TREATED AS A
HUMAN.
THEY AS THE HUMAN THEY ARE AND
BE ADDRESSED WITH RESPECT AND
THE GENDER THEY IDENTIFY S..
SENATE BILL ONE THIRTY TWO WILL
ULTIMATELY GIVE TRANS PEOPLE
COMFORT AND STABILITY SO THEY
CAN FOCUS ON SERVING THEIR
SENTENCES AND PREPARE TO REENTER
SOCIETY.
AS HEALTHIER MORE WELL ADJUSTED
PEOPLE WHO HAVE EXPERIENCE WHAT
IT IS TO BE TREATED WITH DIGNITY
AND RESPECT THANK YOU.
HELLO MEMBERS MY NAME IS MISS A
PULLEY THOUGH I'M NO POLICY
QUITE NEEDED HERE WITH THE TRANS
LATINO COALITION -- WE'RE BASED
IN LOS ANGELES AND PROVIDE
DIRECT SUPPORT TO FORMALLY
INCARCERATED CURRENTLY
INCARCERATED TRANS PEOPLE IN
JAIL PRISON IMMIGRATION
ATTENTION.
TRANSPORT A SPECIALLY TRANS
WOMAN I'M I'M BLACK TRANS PEOPLE
EXPERIENCE OVER POLICING
CRIMINALISATION AT FAR HIGHER
RATES THAN SAYS PEOPLE.
AND BECAUSE OF THIS ONE CHANCE
PEOPLE BECOMING CARS SERRATED.
THE EXPERIENCE A LOT MORE
VIOLENCE THEY DO IN THE OUTSIDE
WORLD TO TO POLICIES AND
PROCEDURES THAT ARE INCLUSIVE OF
TRANS PEOPLE WITHIN CDC ARE.
I'VE HAD THE OPPORTUNITY TO WORK
DIRECTLY IN SUPPORT TRANS FOLKS
IN MANY CITIES ARE FACILITIES
ACROSS THE STATE -- AND MOST TOP
PEOPLE SAY THAT CDC OUR NEEDS TO
DO BETTER.
ACKNOWLEDGING THE LIMITATIONS
THAT DON'T ALLOW FOLKS TO BE IN
THIS ROOM TO PROVIDE TESTIMONY
I'M GOING TO READ ONE FROM A
CURRENTLY INCARCERATED TRANS
WOMAN.
AND A PHOTO OF HER IS HERE.
HELLO MY NAME IS MICHELLE
KILLARNEY CALVIN I AM CURRENTLY
HOUSE AT THE CALIFORNIA
INSTITUTE FOR MEN IN CHINO.
I AM WRITING TO EXPRESS MY
PERSONAL NEEDS TO HAVE SENATE
BILL ONE THIRTY TWO PASSED.
I AM A FORTY EIGHT YEAR OLD MALE
TO FEMALE TRANS WOMAN WHO HAS
BEEN RAPED AS A CHILD FENDED OFF
MULTIPLE ATTEMPTED RAPES DURING
MY INCARCERATION.
AND EVEN ISSUED A RULES
VIOLATION REPORT AND THEN
PUNISHED AFTER THE GUILTY
FINDING.
FOUND GUILTY AND PUNISHED FOR
DEFENDING MYSELF FOR FENDING OFF
ONE OF MY PRIOR CELL MATES WHO
IS TRYING TO RATE ME BACK IN.
TWENTY FIFTEEN WHO WHILE I WAS
HUSBAND QUICK IN STATE PRISON.
SINCE MY ARRIVAL HERE AT CHINO I
HAVE HAD TO FILE A COMPLAINT ON
A PERSON FOR PUSHING ME UP
AGAINST THE WALL WHILE GRABBING
MY ****.
AS HE WAS TELLING ME EXACTLY THE
SPECIFICS OF WHAT HE INTENDED TO
DO TO ME.
AND WHAT HE WAS GOING TO FORCE
ME TO DO TO HIM.
HE THREATENED ME WITH VIOLENCE
IN THE GRADING PUBLIC
HUMILIATION IF I RESISTED TO
REFUSE.
IF I RESISTED A REFUSED TO
COMPLY.
AS THE ONE THIRTY TWO IS
DESIGNED FOR TRANS WOMEN SUCH AS
MYSELF.
IT WILL GIVE US THE OPTION TO
LIVE WITH OTHERS OF LIKE GENDER
A GENDER IDENTITY THAT'S
AVOIDING THAT THAT'S AVOIDING
BEING PUT IN SITUATIONS I JUST
DESCRIBED.
I FACE DISCRIMINATION VERBAL
ABUSE SEXUAL HARASSMENT AND
BULLYING ON AN ONGOING DAILY
BASIS.
I AM CURRENTLY SERVING A LIFE
SENTENCE I AM SINCERELY ASKING
FROM THE BOTTOM OF MY HEART THAT
YOU VOTE TO PASS AS THE ONE
THIRTY TWO IT WILL MAKE A HUGE
AND HUMANE DIFFERENCE FOR ME AND
ALL THE OTHER TRANS WOMEN LIKE
ME.
WHO ARE SERVING TIME IN CDC ARE
THANK YOU?
SB THIRTY TWO WILL NOT FIX ALL
THE PROBLEMS FOR TRANS PEOPLE
NCDC ARW FACILITIES BUT IT WILL
ALLOW US TO START DIALOGUE ABOUT
HOW TO BETTER RESPECT AND PRIDE
DIGNITY THE TRANS FOLKS.
SAID THANK YOU AND I HOPE YOU
VOTE YES ON SB.
ONE THIRTY TWO OKAY ACCORDING TO
THIS FOUR THIRTY SEVENTHS SO.
GO AHEAD -- GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS KELLY LIEU DANS MORE AND
I'M THE LEGAL DIRECTOR AT THE
TRANS GENDER.
GENDER VARIANT INTERSECTS
JUSTICE PROJECT AND I ALSO WANT
TO SHARE A STATEMENT FROM
SOMEBODY -- FROM A TRANSGENDER
WOMAN INSIDE A CDC ARE.
SINCE OUR TO MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC SAFETY COMMITTEE MY NAME
IS LISA RENE BRIGGS I AM A
TRANSGENDER FEMALE WHO IS
CURRENTLY INCARCERATED AT THE
CALIFORNIA INSTITUTE FOR MEN IN
CHINO.
I AM WRITING TO VOICE MY SUPPORT
FOR SB -- ONE THIRTY TìM.
DURING MY TIME OF INCARCERATIONS.
I HAVE NEVER FELT SAFE I'VE BEEN
SEXUALLY ASSAULTED ON TWO
OCCASIONS THE FIRST BY A MALE
INCARCERATED PERSON WHO ATTACKED
ME WHILE I WAS TAKING A SHOWER
AND ATTEMPTED TO RAPE ME.
THE SECOND BY A CORRECTIONAL
LIEUTENANT WHO DURING A SEARCH
REPEATEDLY GROPED ME EVEN AFTER
I TOLD HIM TO STOP.
THE SECOND INCIDENT RESULTED IN
ME BEING HELD IN ADMINISTRATIVE
SEGREGATION FOR OVER THREE
MONTHS.
THIS WENT ON UNTIL I WAS ABLE TO
ENGAGE IN OUTSIDE ATTORNEY WHO
ADVOCATED FOR ME.
ON MY BEHALF I WAS THEN RELEASED
THE AD SAID PLACEMENT WAS
NOTHING MORE THAN RETALIATION.
THESE PAST EXPERIENCES MAKE ME
VERY HESITANT TO REPORT ANY
FURTHER SEXUAL ASSAULTS ARE
HARASSMENTS.
I'VE BEEN DE GENDERED AND
SEXUALLY HARASSED DAILY DURING
MY INCARCERATION BY BOTH
INCARCERATED PEOPLE AS WELL AS
STAFF.
HOWEVER MY STORY IS NOWHERE NEAR
AS BAD OR TRAUMATIC AS MANY
OTHERS.
I ADVOCATE FOR MY SISTERS AND
MYSELF BEHIND BARS AT MY CURRENT
INSTITUTION I HAD TO FIGHT FOR
TRANSGENDER PEOPLE TO HAVE.
SEPARATED SHOWER TIMES AS WELL
AS MODESTY SCREENS SO THAT THOSE
WHO WISH TO COULD SHOOT COULD
SHOWER SEPARATELY FROM THE MAIL
INCARCERATED PEOPLE.
WHO IS SEXUALLY HARASS US ON A
REGULAR BASIS?
I BELIEVE THAT I SHOULD BE ABLE
TO DO MY TIME FREE FROM SEXUAL
AND VERBAL HARASSMENT AND BE
RESPECTED FOR HOWEVER IDENTIFY.
I WOULD PREFER TO FINISH MY
REMAINING TERM OF INCARCERATION
AT A FEMALE INSTITUTION WHERE I
WOULD FEEL MORE COMFORTABLE AND
SAFE I THEREFORE ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE ON SENATE BILL ONE
THIRTY TWO GIVING ME HOPE THAT I
CAN DO MY TIME SAFELY THANK YOU --
OUR DEAR [inaudible]
ANY OTHER.
IN SUPPORT NAME AN ORGANIZATION.
KATHY SURE FOR THE ACLU OF
CALIFORNIA -- PROUD TO CO
SPONSOR THIS LEGISLATION.
MARCO GEORGE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
RESIDENTS ALSO ME HALF OF THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS HERE IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
TAMMY MARTIN ON BEHALF OF
EQUALITY CALIFORNIA AS WELL AS
LAND LEGAL BOTH PROUD BECAUSE
SPONSORS OF THE BILL AND STRONG
SUPPORT.
JIM LINDBERGH ON BEHALF OF THE
FRIENDS COMMITTEE ON LEGISLATION
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
OMAR GARCIA OF TRANSGENDER
LAWCENTER FULLY SUPPORT.
OF FREDDIE FRANCIS FOR BAY AREA
LAWYERS OF FOR INDIVIDUAL
FREEDOM AND TRANSGENDER ADVOCACY
GROUP STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK.
JENNIFER OR THE ONE ON BEHALF OF
THE NORTH ONE OCCUR OWNED A LAW
FIRM THAT REPRESENTS TRANSGENDER
PEOPLE IN PRISON.
WE STRONGLY SUPPORT AND OUR
SPONSOR THIS BILL.
GOING BACK IS FOR ELLA BAKER
CENTER FOR HUMAN RIGHTS IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
OTHER ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
YES COULD YOU MAKE THANK YOU
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN
[inaudible]
SURE MEMBERS.
MY NAME IS ABIGAIL INADA.
I AM A DEMOCRAT.
A FEMINIST AND AN ADVOCATE FOR
WOMEN'S RIGHTS.
I AM HERE TODAY BECAUSE OF SB
ONE THIRTY TWO AS IT IS
CURRENTLY WRITTEN BECOMES LAW.
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA WILL
SANCTION THE DESIRE OF MALE
RAPISTS. TO SHARE QUARTERS WITH
FEMALE INMATES.
LEST YOU THINK THIS IS HYPERBOLE.
IT'S ALREADY HAPPENING.
RIGHT NOW RICHARD MáS BROKE A
TRANS IDENTIFIED MAIL.
IS CURRENTLY HOUSED WITH FEMALE
INMATES IN CORONA CALIFORNIA.
EVEN THOUGH HE IS SERVING TIME
FOR TARGETING RAPING.
AND TORTURING WOMEN.
UNDER NO CIRCUMSTANCES IS THIS
MORALLY JUSTIFIABLE.
THIS BILL PERMITS MALE INMATES
TO BE HOUSED WITH FEMALE INMATES
AT THE MERE REQUEST OF A MAIL IN
MEAT.
EVEN THOUGH MALES COMMIT VIOLENT
CRIMES THREE TIMES MORE OFTEN
THAN WOMEN.
AND THERE ARE NO STUDIES TO SHOW
THAT MALES WHO SELF IDE AS TRANS
COMMIT LESS VIOLENT CRIMES
RELATIVE. TO THE GENERAL MALE
POPULATION.
THIS BILL PROVIDES NO EXCEPTIONS
FOR MALE INMATES WHO HAVE
COMMITTED VIOLENT CRIMES OR
CRIMES AGAINST WOMEN.
INCLUDING RAPE SEXUAL ASSAULT OR
HARASSMENT.
THIS BILL DOES NOT REQUIRE
OFFICIALS TO CONSIDER ANATOMY A
DIAGNOSIS OF GENDER DYSPHORIA OR
A MENTAL HEALTH DIAGNOSIS.
IT DOES NOT REQUIRE A MAIL IN
MAY TWO PHYSICALLY PRESENT AS A
WOMAN TAKES STEPS TO MEDICALLY
TRANSITION NOR EVEN TO PREFER
FEMININE PRONOUNS.
ALL THAT IS REQUIRED ACCORDING
TO THIS BILL IS A MALE INMATES
DESIRE TO BE HOUSED WITH WOMEN.
EVEN IF THAT MAIL IS
INCARCERATED FOR SEXUAL CRIMES
AGAINST WOMEN.
IF PASSED.
THIS BILL WOULD ALSO COST THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS AN INCREASE LEGAL
SETTLEMENTS.
THE DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS IS
ALREADY KNOWN TO HAVE A VERY
HIGH RATE OF SEX HARASSMENT
CLAIMS WHICH HAS COST TAXPAYERS
MILLIONS IN COURT BATTLES.
WHERE LAWS LIKE SB ONE THIRTY TO
HAVE ALREADY BEEN IMPLEMENTED IT
HAS RESULTED IN MALE INMATES
SEXUALLY ASSAULTING FEMALE
INMATES?
THE POLICY HAS BEEN SO EGREGIOUS
IN THE UNITED KINGDOM.
THAT THEY HAVE HAD TO ROLL BACK
THEIR SELF ID POLICY.
IN ORDER TO PROTECT FEMALE
INMATES FROM FURTHER SEXUAL
ASSAULT.
THEY HAVE SINCE ESTABLISHED A
SEPARATE TRANS GENDER UNIT. TO
PROTECT ALL INMATES.
I STRONGLY RECOMMEND THAT ANYONE
DRAFTING THIS BILL.
LOOK INTO OTHER PLACES WHERE
THIS IS HAPPENING [inaudible] TO
COMPARE.
THE GOAL TO PRESERVE THE SAFETY
OF TRANS IDENTIFIED INMATES IS A
NOBLE.
ONE BUT IT IS IMPERATIVE THAT
THE PUBLIC SAFETY COMMITTEE
ACHIEVE THIS GOAL.
WITHOUT COMPROMISING THE SAFETY
OF CALIFORNIA'S FEMALE INMATE
POPULATION.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME THANK
YOU YES SIR.
SURE MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO ADDRESS YOU TODAY
MY NAME IS GREG BIRCH I WORK FOR
THE CALIFORNIA FAMILY COUNCIL --
MISS LOW LUNA -- DID A GREAT JOB
EXPLAINING HOW THIS BILL TRIES
TO SOLVE A LEGITIMATE PROBLEM
WITH THE TERRIBLE SOLUTION.
THAT PUTS VULNERABLE WOMEN
INMATES AT RISK.
BUT I WANT TO TRY AND GIVE YOU A
PERSPECTIVE THE AVERAGE PERSON.
I CHALLENGE YOU TO JUST RANDOMLY
WALK UP TO SOMEONE ON THE STREET
AND ASK THEM WHAT THEY THINK
ABOUT LEADING MAIL IN MAYES
DECIDE IF THEY WANT TO BE HOUSE
WITH WOMEN.
AND WE'RE ONLY TALKING ABOUT MEN
HERE YOU ARE GOING TO HAVE ANY
BIOLOGICAL WOMEN DECIDE THEY
WOULD RATHER BE HOUSE IN THE
MEN'S PRISON.
HERE'S SOME COMMENTS I PULLED
FROM FACEBOOK IN REACTION TO
THIS BILL.
THIS CANNOT BE TRUE.
THIS IS SO STUPID I GIVE UP.
JUST ANOTHER INSANE IDEA IN
CALIFORNIA.
HERE'S A COMMENT.
I HAVE A SISTER THAT WORKS IN
THE CALIFORNIA PRISON SYSTEM AND
SHE TOLD ME STORIES ABOUT MEN
SAYING THEY WERE WOMEN TO GET
INTO THE WOMEN'S PRISON AND THEN
ATTACKING WOMEN THERE.
WHAT A FIASCO THIS WILL BE IT
ALSO GIVES PRISONERS A HOLDOVER
GUARDS IN OFFICIALS WITH THAT
FURTHER CLOGS UP THE JUDICIAL
SYSTEM WITH FOR THE MOST
FRIVOLOUS LAWSUITS?
OF THE CON ARTISTS IN PRISON ARE
LAUGHING NOW.
HOW ABOUT THIS ONE HARVEY
WEINSTEIN IS GOING TO HAVE A
GREAT TIME IN PRISON ALL HAS TO
DO IS SAY I'M A FEMALE AND HE'LL
BE HOUSE WITH THE FEMALES?
SEXUAL ABUSE -- HERE COMES THIS
THERE WAS A ONE COMMENT FROM A
PERSON WHO THOUGHT THIS IS A
GOOD IDEA.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER'S YOU ARE LIVING
IN A BUBBLE IF YOU THINK
CALIFORNIA VOTERS WANT THIS.
COMMONSENSE SCREAMS OUT.
THIS IS A REALLY REALLY BAD IDEA.
AND I'LL WRAP UP HERE -- IF YOU
PASS THIS IN GOVERNOR NUISANCE
SIGNS IT HERE'S WHAT I HOPE
HAPPENS THE FIRST DAY THE BILL
GOES INTO EFFECT.
I HOPE EVERY MALE IN ME ALL AT
ONCE DECLARE THEMSELVES TO BE A
WOMAN AND ASKED TO BE HOUSING
THE WOMAN'S PRISON WHAT WILL YOU
DO THEN.
THIS BILL WILL ALLOW SUCH A
SITUATION COMPLETE CHAOS ONCE TO
THE VOTERS THE COUNTRY WILL HANG
THEIR HEADS IN SHAME.
KNOWING THAT THE STATE IN THIS
UNION WOULD BE WILLING TO PASS A
BILL LIKE THIS IF YOU REALLY
CARE ABOUT WOMEN SAFETY YOU'LL
OPPOSE SB ONE THIRTY TWO SO
PLEASE PLEASE VOTE NOW.
THANK YOU.
ARE THERE ANY OTHER.
ANYONE ELSE IN OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL.
ARE ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
MISS REBEKAH POWER QUE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
[inaudible]
SO.
I THANK THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING
THIS BILL I THINK IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT WE PROTECT OUR TRANS
COMMUNITY IN OUR PRISONS AND I
THINK YOU'RE DOING THE RIGHT
THING.
BUT I THINK THE OPPOSITION
RAISES A SERIOUS CONCERN BECAUSE
THERE ARE A LOT OF PEOPLE IN OUR
PRISON POPULATION THAT ARE NOT
HONEST ACTORS.
AND HOW DO WE PREVENT FROM
WRONGDOING ON THOSE PARTS OF YOU
THOUGHT ABOUT THAT IS THERE
SOMETHING IN THE BILL PROTECTS
ABOUT IT WHAT'S YOUR RESPONSE
THANK YOU -- SO -- I COULD SEE A
LOT OF THINGS TO SOME OF THE
COMMENTS THAT WERE MADE.
BY THE OPPOSITION -- AND IF YOU --
WANT TO HAVE A GREATER
UNDERSTANDING FOR WHY IT IS SO
HARD TO BE A TRANSGENDER PERSON
IN THIS COUNTRY.
OR IN THIS WORLD OR WHY TRANS
PEOPLE WHY WE KNOW THAT JUST
JUST THIS MONTH OF JUNE FOR
TRANS WOMEN OF FOR AFRICAN
AMERICAN TRANS WOMEN.
HAVE BEEN MURDERED TRUST IN THE
MONTH OF JUNE WE HAVE AN
EPIDEMIC OF TRANS WOMEN IN
PARTICULAR IN THIS COUNTRY BEING
BRUTALIZED AND MURDERED.
IF YOU WANT TO HAVE ANY
UNDERSTANDING ABOUT THE
CONVERSATION AROUND THIS BILL
GIVES YOU A GLIMPSE INTO THAT.
AND WE THOUGHT PLAY ALL AND
EVERY ARGUMENT WE HEAR TODAY.
WAS MADE IN JUSTIFICATION IN
SUPPORT OF THE NORTH CAROLINA
BATHROOM BILL IF YOU REMEMBER
THAT IN THE NEWS THAT TRANS
PEOPLE ARE ALL SOCIOPATHS.
THE TRANS PEOPLE JUST BECOME
TRANS SO THEY CAN.
GO INTO WOMEN'S BATHROOM -- AND
RAPED AND MOLESTED WOMEN
REMEMBER THOSE ARGUMENTS THAT WE
WERE HEARING OUT OF NORTH
CAROLINA AND REMEMBER THE
JUSTIFIED NATIONAL BACKLASH.
AGAINST DOT PERSPECTIVE -- THAT
TRANSPORT NOT REALLY TRANSIT
JUST CAN USE TRICKERY AND TO SAY
OF PAY -- ARE IDENTIFIED AS A
WOMAN IN ORDER TO GET ACCESS TO
SOMETHING -- THIS IS A
POPULATION THAT IS.
KNOWS IS SO INCREDIBLY
MARGINALIZED IN OUR SOCIETY AND
PARTICULARLY IN THE PRISON
SYSTEM AND WE COULD GIVE YOU I
DON'T HAVE TO I DON'T HAVE TO
READ FACEBOOK.
COMMENTS TO YOU TO SHOW YOU THE
STATISTICS OF HELL BRUTALIZED
TRANSFERABLE ARE IN PRISON
TRANSFORM THE ONES BRUTALIZING
OTHER PEOPLE THEY ARE THE ONES
BEING VICTIMIZED AND THIS BILL
WILL HELP.
PROTECT THEM.
THE BILL PROVIDES FLEXIBILITY
FOR CDC ARE IF THERE IS A
SPECIFIC SECURITY CONCERN ABOUT
INDIVIDUAL. TO TAKE ACTION.
IT'S IF THAT'S WRITTEN INTO THE
BILL -- BUT I I THINK THAT THIS
IS NOT THIS IS NOT IS AN ISSUE
THAT IS BEING ARTICULATED.
AND THERE'S I DON'T THINK ANY
SUBSTANCE TO IT -- AND SO --
WE'RE ALL CONCERNED WITH THE
SECURITY OF ALL OF OUR
INCARCERATED INDIVIDUALS.
BY THE VICTIMIZATION OF
HAPPENING.
IS TRANSGENDER BEING PEOPLE
BEING VICTIMIZED BECAUSE OF THE
WAY THAT WE ARE TREATING THEM
AND OUR PRISON SYSTEM.
THANK YOU KNOW I I HAVE TO AGREE
AND I THINK THAT YOU KNOW.
WE HEAR COMMENTS ALL THE TIME TO
MAKE IT CLEAR WHY WE NEED TO
PROTECT OUR TRANS COMMUNITIES
AND I THINK ESPECIALLY IN
PRISONS WHERE PEOPLE ARE
VICTIMIZED.
AND WE NEED TO MAKE SURE
PROTECTING THEM AND I APPRECIATE
THAT THERE IS FLEXIBILITY ON THE
PART OF CDC ARE SO IF THERE IS
SOMEONE.
AS DESCRIBED BY THE FIRST
OPPOSITION WITNESS WHO -- IS NOT
A FACTOR THAN THEY WANTED SO
THANK YOU.
AND CRAP YEAH AND FOR THE IF YOU
WANT SOME OF THOSE STATISTICS
ALSO -- ACCORDING TO A STUDY BY
UC IRVINE 59% OF TRANS WOMEN
HELD IN MEN'S PRISONS WERE
SEXUALLY ABUSED COMPARED 24% OF
JUSTICE PEOPLE IN THE MEN'S
PRISONS.
AND THE NATIONALLY TRANS PEOPLE
ARE INCARCERATED ARE FIVE TO SIX
TIMES MORE LIKELY THAN THE
GENERAL POPULATION TO BE
SEXUALLY ASSAULTED BY FACILITY
STAFF.
AND NINE TO TEN STE NINE TO TEN
TIMES MORE LIKELY TO BE SEXUALLY
ASSAULTED BY ANOTHER
INCARCERATED PERSON.
AND SO THE LIKELIHOOD THAT FOLKS
ARE GOING TO GO INTO WOMEN'S
PRISONS AND DO WHAT THEY ARE
DESCRIBING IS IS IS VERY
UNLIKELY AND I THINK THERE NEEDS
TO BE A MORE.
IN DEPTH LOOK AT HOW
CORRECTIONAL OFFICERS ACTUALLY
TREATING TRANSPORT A HOT
TRANSPORT TREATING PEOPLE IN
WATER INCARCERATED -- AND SO I
JUST WANTED TO ADD THAT AWESOME.
THANKS AGAIN IT HAPPENED ALMOST
IMMEDIATELY WHEN THAT WAS
IMPLEMENTED IN THE UNITED
KINGDOM.
GENDER SELF ID AS SOON AS IT WAS
IMPLEMENTED THERE WERE SEXUAL
ASSAULTS.
THAT WERE DONE.
IMPLEMENT THAT WERE.
TRANSLATE INTO FIVE MALES DID
THAT TO WOMEN THAT IS WHY THEY
CREATED A SEPARATE.
UNIT.
IT HAPPENED ALMOST IMMEDIATELY.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR COMMENTS IS
THERE ANY OTHER QUESTIONS.
AND COME OVER.
TO MAKING HER -- BRINGING THIS
ARM I THINK RATHER IDEALISTIC
BILL -- TO THE ASSEMBLY I HAVE
SOME QUESTIONS MYSELF I AM NOT.
A AND I DON'T KNOW HOW TO PHRASE
THIS APPROPRIATELY I DON'T KNOW
IF I'M AS CONCERNED BECAUSE I
BELIEVE THE STATISTICS THAT ARE
OUT THERE ABOUT TRANS REGARDLESS
OF YOUR INCARCERATED OR NOT OKAY
BEING TRAUMATIZED AND ASSAULTED.
BUT I DO SORT OF QUESTION --
WHAT'S IN THE BILL WHAT KIND OF
LANGUAGES IN THE BILL THAT
REALLY TALKS TO THOSE FOLKS WHO
PURPORT TO BE TRANS -- WHO MAY
WANT TO FIND THEIR WAY INTO A
PARTICULAR FACILITY -- TO DO TO
CREATE ALL KIND OF MAYHEM -- SO
THAT'S ONE QUESTION THE OTHER
QUESTION I HAVE IS I WOULD JUST
LIKE TO HEAR FROM THE AUTHOR AND
THE EXPERTS.
ABOUT THE CAPACITY OF THE PRISON
SYSTEM TO ACTUALLY ACCOMMODATE
THIS I THINK IT'S MUCH BROADER
THAN A PRONOUN I THINK WHAT YOU
SAID IN YOUR TESTIMONY YOU KNOW
THIS IS NOT GOING TO FIX IT BUT
HOPEFULLY IT WILL START A
DIALOGUE.
IS INCREDIBLY ACUTELY ACCURATE --
BUT I JUST AM CURIOUS ABOUT YOU
KNOW THAT.
BECAUSE WE REALLY SHOULD BE
TALKING ABOUT HOW TO HAVE A
CULTURE CHANGE WITHIN THE PRISON
SYSTEM.
YOU KNOW THERE ARE TRANS FOLKS
WERE BEING ASSAULTED AND
MOLESTED AND RAPED BUT THEY'RE
ALSO SAYS WOMEN -- AND MEN WHO
ARE BEING YOU KNOW.
ASSAULTED AND RAPED AND THEN
BASED ON YOUR ETHNICITY.
YOU HAVE SITUATIONS WHERE FOLKS
ARE BEING TARGETED IF THEY'RE
NOT FROM THE SAME GANG IF
THEY'RE FROM A DIFFERENT GANG IF
THEY'RE A DIFFERENT RACE OR IF
THEY'RE DIFFERENT ETHNICITY OR A
DIFFERENT RELIGION.
I MEAN ALL OF THIS KIND OF
TRAUMA IS HAPPENING YOU KNOW IN
THESE -- PRISON SYSTEMS AND I
CERTAINLY DON'T BELIEVE THAT CDC
ARE HAS THE CAPACITY TO EVEN
MANAGES ACTS.
SO I JUST WONDER BECAUSE YOU
TALKED ABOUT THAT THERE'S
LANGUAGE IN THE BILL THAT TALKS
ABOUT THE FLEXIBILITY THAT CDC
OUR HOUSE IF YOU CAN KIND OF
SPEAK TO THE BROADER ISSUE
BECAUSE MY FEAR IS THAT WE THEN
HAVE THIS HAPPEN.
AND I DON'T WANT TO GET MORE
STATS ARE REPORTS ABOUT MORE
TRANS FOLKS BEING HURT BECAUSE
WE'VE SORT OF CHANGED A SYSTEM
THAT REALLY ISN'T.
PREPARED AND THEN SAID OKAY
LET'S CREATE THE IDEAL IN THE
REAL.
AND THEN WE HAVE MORE CHAOS
BECAUSE THAT'S I MEAN YOU KNOW
DOING THAT I THINK IS EQUAL TO
ACTUALLY DOING NOTHING AND
SAYING YOU KNOW SCREW YOU YOU'RE
INCARCERATED DEAL WITH IT.
YEAH AND JUST SO IN IN CRAFTING
THIS AND OBVIOUSLY WE ARE
WORKING CLOSELY WITH A A BROAD
COALITION -- BY INCLUDING WITH.
TRANS PEOPLE WHO ARE
INCARCERATED OR WERE
INCARCERATED WHO UNDERSTAND ON
THE GROUND.
WHAT IS GOING TO PROTECT THEIR
SAFETY SO IT DOT?
WHAT HOWARD PRACTICE WAS NOT
DONE IN A IN A VACUUM?
I AND AND THAT'S WHY THE BILL
ALSO CREATES FLEXIBILITY -- THAT
A TRANS PERSONS OWN SENSE OF
SAFETY AND HEALTH IS.
IS FACTORED IN -- CDC ARE -- WE
HAVE BEEN REGULARLY MEETING WITH
CDC ARE -- STARTING BEFORE WE
INTRODUCE THIS BILL SIGNED LAST
YEAR I NCDC ARW I GOT I DON'T I
DON'T SPEAK FOR CC I DON'T WANT
TO SPEAK FOR THEM BUT THEY
REPORT TO US THAT THEY WANT TO
MOVE IN THIS DIRECTION IN FACT
THEY HAVE A WORKING GROUP.
INTERNALLY ON TO MOVE IN THIS
DIRECTION -- AND SO I DON'T
THINK WE'RE ENCOUNTERING A
AGENCY THAT IS SAYING NO WE
CAN'T OR DON'T WANT TO DO THIS
THEY WANT TO GET THEIR ON'T.
CLEARLY THERE ARE A LOT OF
PROBLEMS IN OUR PRISON SYSTEM
AROUND VIOLENCE AND MANY MANY
OTHER ISSUES.
AND I'M NOT GOING TO SIT HERE
AND SAY SB ONE THIRTY TWO IS
GOING TO LIE TO MAGICALLY FIX AT
ALL STILL GONNA TAKE A LOT OF
WORK WITH THIS IS.
ONE STOP -- FOR ONE INMATE
POPULATION THAT HAS A LOT OF
CHALLENGES AND SO I THINK THAT
THIS WILL NOT SOLVE EVERYTHING
BUT MOVE US IN A GOOD DIRECTION
I DON'T KNOW IF -- IF MACHE OR
NOT YEAH YEAH AND AGAIN LIKE I
SAID IN MY TESTIMONY IT ISN'T
GOING TO FIX EVERYTHING AND I
THINK IT'S REALLY AN OPPORTUNITY
TO CREATE DIALOGUE AROUND.
WHO TRANS PEOPLE ARE AND LIKE
THE SPECIFIC ISSUES THAT THEY
FACE ALL INCARCERATED WHICH IS
VERY RECENT THAT'S COME UP TO
THE LEGISLATURE AND I THINK WHAT
MAKES?
OUR WORK ON THIS BILL SO
IMPORTANT IS THAT WE'RE DOING ON
THE GROUND DIRECT SUPPORT TO
INCARCERATED PEOPLE WORKING
DIRECTLY WITH CDC ARE AND THEN
TRYING TO PUSH FOR STATEWIDE
LEGISLATION AND SO.
ALL THREE OF THOSE MERGING
FACTORS I THINK ARE CRAFTING --
A PROCESS AND CRAFTING QUICK
SORT OF A SOLUTION THAT'S GONNA
HELP INCARCERATED TRANS FOLKS IF
THIS BILL WERE TO BE PASSED AND
SO IT'S I THINK THE REALLY
TRANSPARENT AND HONEST
CONVERSATIONS ARE HAVING CCDC
ARE ARE HAVE BEEN REALLY HELPFUL
AND LIKE DETERMINING.
HOW WE WOULD SCREEN PEOPLE FROM?
FROM BECAUSE LIKE FOR PREDATORY
PEOPLE FROM GOING INTO WOMEN'S
UNLIKELY IT COULD BE A
POSSIBILITY AND WE ARE TAKING
THAT INTO CONSIDERATION AND SO I
THINK -- WE ARE HAVING ONGOING
DIALOGUE AND I CAN'T STRESS THAT
ENOUGH BECAUSE I THINK THAT --
WERE REALLY REALLY TRYING TO BE
INTENTIONAL WITH THIS BILL.
SO I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR THOSE
COMMENTS YOU KNOW I GONNA JUST
ADD THAT YOU KNOW I'M SKEPTICAL
BUT I'M NOT GOING TO GET IN THE
WAY OF TRYING AND YOU WON'T KNOW
UNTIL YOU TRY.
AND THEN YOU JUST MOVE FROM
THERE [inaudible]
MR MATHIS.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I'M JUST
[inaudible]
CURIOUS BECAUSE PULLING UP THE
OPPOSITION STUFF WITHOUT THE
SOLUTION THAT THEY DID IN.
THE U. K..
THEY ENDED UP DOING A SEPARATE
FACILITY FOR TRANS GENDERED.
AND MY QUESTION SENATORS HOW
COME WE HAVEN'T LOOKED AT DOING
THAT -- YOU KNOW INSTEAD OF
RUNNING THIS LEGISLATION RUN
SOMETHING TO SET UP ME EITHER
SEPARATE BLOCK.
OR SOMETHING ALONG THOSE LINES
TO HAVE A SEPARATE.
I MEAN IF THIS SONY MESSED UP
THEY'RE GOING TO PRISON THEIR
GOING TO PRISON CELL.
DO WE NEED TO LOOK AT DOING LIKE
A SEVER PRESENT FOR TRANS GENDER
TO MAKE SURE THEY HAVE ALL THE
NEEDS IN FACILITIES AND
PROTECTIONS AND EVERYTHING THAT
THEY NEED.
AND THAT THOSE CORRECTIONAL
GUARDS THERE HAVE SPECIAL
TRAINING TO ENSURE THEY KNOW HOW
TO TREAT PEOPLE.
I MEAN THEY SHOULD BE TREATING
PEOPLE RIGHT ANYWAY BUT JUST TO
REALLY ENSURE THAT EVERYTHING'S
THERE AND ALL THE NEEDS ARE MET.
YES SO I MEAN THAT'S I I'M JUST
WONDERING WHY WE'RE GOING IN
THIS DIRECTION WHEN WE KNOW
THERE'S A MODEL OVER HERE WE
KNOW THERE WAS PROBLEMS OVER
HERE.
INSTEAD OF LOOKING AT OKAY THIS
IS HOW THEY SOLVED IT.
AND NOW THINGS ARE BETTER THERE
WHY WE ARE JUST LOOKING AT
LESSONS LEARNED FROM OTHER
COUNTRIES LIKE WE DO WITH A LOT
OF OTHER THINGS.
BECAUSE TRANS WOMEN ARE WOMEN
TRANSGENDER MATT -- AND I DON'T
SO I DON'T THINK YOU -- THE SALE
CREATED. FOR A TRANSGENDER
PRISON WERE OVER SAYING IS THAT
IF YOU'RE TRANSFORM AND YOUR
WOMAN.
YOU SHOULD BE ABLE TO BE HOUSED
AS A WOMAN AND BY I UNDERSTAND
THAT'S THAT YOUR FEELINGS ON A
WERE TALKING ABOUT PRISON
POPULATIONS AND SUB CULTURES
THAT ALL HAVE THEIR OWN VERY.
DIFFERENT FEELINGS WITHIN THOSE
JUSTICE -- MISS KAMLAGER-DOVE
POINTED OUT EVEN IN REGULAR
PRESENCE YOU STILL HAVE GANG
MEMBERS.
RACIAL RIGHTS AND EVERYTHING
ELSE HAPPENING WE'RE REYES AND
THESE THINGS ARE STILL HAPPENING.
SO I MEAN WE'RE NOT GONNA BE
ABLE TO CHANGE THE SUBCULTURES
WITHIN THE PRESENT OVERNIGHT.
AND I AM I AM NOT -- MY OPINIONS
ON ON ON IT IT.
IS GOING TO CHANGE THE
SUBCULTURE WHAT.
IF OUR OUR JOB IS TO FIGURE OUT
A SOLUTION IS GOING TO BE.
ADVERTISE POPULATION SAY.
YEAH WE'RE NOT TRYING TO AS I
STATED TO SOLVE OUR PROBLEM AND
PRISONS OFFICER THERE MANY
PROBLEMS -- BUT WE'RE LOOKING
ADDRESS ONE SPECIFIC ISSUE --
GUY TRANSGENDER AND CAR SERRATED
PEOPLE ARE BEING.
I THOUGHT [inaudible]
I NOT HOUSE CORRECTLY.
AMONG OTHER THINGS -- WHICH
LEADS TO INCREASED VIOLENCE
AGAINST SOME AND OTHER PROBLEMS
WERE TRYING TO ADDRESS A ONE
SPECIFIC ISSUE UNDERSTANDING
THAT THERE ARE.
BROADER AND OTHER ISSUES THAT
NEED TO BE ADDRESSED IN THE
PRISON SYSTEM.
YEAH AND I THINK IT'S A
COALITION A COMMUNITY LIKE.
NOT AT ALL WOULD BE ONE ADVOCATE
FOR THE CONSTRUCTION OF A NEW
PRISON LIKE WE WOULDN'T WANT TO
CREATE A WHOLE NEW FACILITY FOR
TRANS PEOPLE LIKE THAT'S WHAT
WE'RE TRYING TO MOVE AWAY FROM.
AND I THINK ADVOCATING FOR A
SEPARATE FACILITY FOR THEIR
STIGMATIZES FURTHER MARGINALIZES
OUR COMMUNITY -- BY SAYING THAT.
LIKE WHERE A WHOLE DIFFERENT
LIKE ENTITY AND LIKE.
JUST MAKES US LIKE.
IT MAKES IT SEEM LIKE ALIENS OR
SOMETHING LIKE WE HAVE TO BE
TRANSFERRED TO A WHOLE DIFFERENT
PLACE AND IT'S LIKE.
PRISON RAPE IS STILL HAPPENING
WOMEN'S FACILITIES REGARDLESS OF
TRANS WOMEN WEAR TRANSFERRED
THERE ARE NOT BY CORRECTIONAL
OFFICERS AND BY OTHER PEOPLE
WITHIN THOSE FACILITIES AND SO I
CAN'T REITERATE ENOUGH THAT.
THIS IS REALLY ABOUT VALIDATING
THE EXPERIENCES OF TRANS PEOPLE
AS TRANSAMINASES WOMEN AND TRANS
MEN AS MEN -- AND SO I WANTED TO
REPEAT THAT SO YOU'RE SAYING
THAT REYES HAPPENS USING THEM
YOU DON'T ASK THEM QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AND ARE YOU
[inaudible]
HE DONE.
NOW IS THE SAME THANK.
OF AND THEN -- ANYMORE QUESTIONS
OR STATEMENTS I'D I'D IS AND WE
OUGHT TO LOOK AT LESSONS LEARNED
[inaudible]
OKAY YOU -- ANYMORE.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE THANK.
AND SO I I LOOK I I CAN SEE PART
OF THE THE DILEMMA -- THAT MAYBE
SOME MAY HAVE.
OF EVEN THE OPPOSITION I CAN CAN
CONSIDER CONCERN [inaudible]
OF LOOK.
THE THERE WAS A TIME.
WHERE MY UNCLE COULDN'T GO TO
THE SAME SCHOOL?
AS WHITE SKIDS BECAUSE IT WOULD
MONGOL ICE.
OR AFTER AMERICAN MALES WOULD
RAPE WHITE WOMEN DICTATE WENT TO
SCHOOL TOGETHER.
LITTLE ROCK CENTRAL HIGH SCHOOL.
WHENEVER PEOPLE MAKING THOSE
CLAIMS -- BECAUSE THEY DIDN'T
UNDERSTAND.
AFTER AMERICAN.
WHITE KIDS COMING TOGETHER IN
THE SCHOOL AND LEARNING TOGETHER.
I THINK WE'RE JUST NOW REALLY
TRYING TO UNDERSTAND THE TRANS
COMMUNITY THIS IS ALL.
NEW TO US AND HOW.
ON THE TRANS COMMUNITY THANKS
HOLLY OPERATE.
AND WHERE WE'RE GOING WITH.
SOME THINGS THAT NATURE THAT'S
ONE OF THE PROBLEMS TO I I CAN
LET THE OPPOSITION NOW -- CCPOA
AND I'VE.
THE CALIFORNIA CORRECTIONAL
PEACE OFFICERS ASSOCIATION I
ASKED HIM ABOUT.
YOU KNOW TRANSCEND OF ISSUES
THAT ARE IN CARS RATED AND HOW
COULD YOU.
ARE YOU ABLE TO TELL.
AND THEY EVIDENTLY HAVE SOME
VERY VERY -- ANY PARTY REASON
YOU HAVE THIS BILL THAT IT'S
REALLY HARD TO IDENTIFY AND
IMPRISON PICTURED YOUR TRANS.
AND SO -- CCPOA MEMBERS HAVE
TOLD ME WE KNOW AND WE CAN MAKE
SURE.
THAT INDIVIDUALS AND NOW. EIGHTY
SO OUT OUT.
HOW QUICKLY MAKE MY STATEMENTS?
SO WE GET TO THE VOTE -- BUT
CCPOA NEEDS TO MOVE TO THE NEXT
DIRECTION I BELIEVE THEY ARE
WILLING TO MOVE WITH ALL THE
SECURITY.
CONSIDERATIONS THEY ARE THEY'RE
BETTER EQUIPPED AT BRING IN THIS
AND IF THEY NEED ADDITIONAL
FUNDING AGAIN THAT'S GOING TO
COME BACK ON ME IN THE END OF
COMMITTEE HIGH MAN. TO TRY -- TO
MAKE SURE OF FACILITY I'M NOT
CERTAIN -- GO WITH A SEPARATE
FACILITY BUT THEY WILL COME UP
WITH A MECHANISM THAT WORKS FOR
EVERYBODY AND KEEP EVERYONE SAFE
FROM WITH THAT I RECOMMEND AN
AYE VOTE.
HONESTY ONE THIRTY TO THE MOTION
IS TO PASS TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE JONES SAWYER JONES --
I LACKEY LACKEY NO BARRICADE HAD
PARA QUE HANNAH I MATHIS.
MATH IS NOT VOTING KAMLAGER-DOVE.
KAMLAGER-DOVE I QUIRK.
SANTIAGO SANTIAGO I WICKS.
WICKS I THANK YOU FOR THE
MEASURE PASSES.
SO WE MAY HAVE TO GO BACK AND
GET A WHERE DID YOU GO
[inaudible]
SO -- YEAH JUST GO THROUGH AND
SEE WHAT WE AND IT WILL GO.
OKAY SO I NEED TO KNOW HOW MANY
SO I CAN GET HIM OVER HERE
[inaudible]
OKAY.
SO THE MEMBERS SO THE MEMBERS
THAT ARE HERE.
THAT THAT BEEN MISSING I WANT TO
GET THERE [inaudible]
BOB.
THE OTHER MEMBERS.
ON ITEM NUMBER ONE SB TWENTY
THREE STILL PENDING.
ITEM NUMBER TWO SB.
THIRTY FIVE BY SENATOR CHIANG
KAMLAGER-DOVE.
KAMLAGER-DOVE I ITEM NUMBER
THREE SB FORTY TWO BY SENATOR
SCANNER LACKEY.
HI LACKEY I ITEM NUMBER FOUR SB
FIFTY FIVE WAS PULLED BY THE
AUTHOR.
ITEM NUMBER FIVE SB.
SIXTY ONE WICKS.
WICKS HI THIS MEASURE STILL LONG
CALL.
ITEM NUMBER SIX IS MEASURE WAS
PULLED BY THE AUTHOR.
ITEM NUMBER SEVEN SB ONE THIRTY
TWO QUIRK.
ITEM NUMBER EIGHT SB ONE THIRTY
SIX BARRICADE HAND BARRICADE HAD
I ITEM NUMBER NINE SB ONE
SEVENTY TWO BY SENATOR
PORTANTINO MATHIS.
ITEM NUMBER NINE SB [inaudible]
ONE SEVENTY TWO MATHIS NO.
ITEM NUMBER TEN SB.
ONE NINETY THREE BY SENATOR
NIELSEN KAMLAGER-DOVE
[inaudible]
KAMLAGER-DOVE NO.
ITEM NUMBER ELEVEN SB TWO THIRTY
BY SENATOR COMMA YET ALL
KAMLAGER-DOVE [inaudible]
KAMLAGER-DOVE NOT [inaudible]
VOTING [inaudible]
I'M SORRY.
EXCUSE ME KAMLAGER-DOVE I YES
MA'AM THEY WERE SENT -- TO NEVER
CITY ON FRIDAY [inaudible]
YES.
I DON'T NUMBER TWELVE SB TWO
THIRTY NINE WAS ON CONSENT.
ITEM THIRTEEN SB TWO FIFTY NINE
WAS ON CONSENT.
ITEM NUMBER FOURTEEN SB TWO
EIGHTY TWO BY SENATOR PELL
KAMLAGER-DOVE.
KAMLAGER-DOVE I SANTIAGO WICKS.
WICKS HI THIS MEASURE PASSES.
I DON'T EVER FIFTEEN SB THREE OH
FOUR BY SENATOR HILL LACKEY.
LACKEY I KAMLAGER-DOVE
[inaudible]
KAMLAGER-DOVE I ITEM NUMBER
SIXTEEN SB THIRTY THREE SEVENTY
FIVE BY CENTERED BUT ALSO
KAMLAGER-DOVE [inaudible]
KAMLAGER-DOVE I ITEM NUMBER
SEVENTEEN WAS PULLED BY.
THE COMMITTEE ITEM NUMBER
EIGHTEEN SB THREE NINETY THREE
KAMLAGER-DOVE.
KAMLAGER-DOVE OF NO.
ITEM NUMBER NINETEEN THIS
MEASURE WAS ON CALL SB THREE
NINETY FOUR BY SENATOR SKINNER.
JONES SAWYER.
JONES SAWYER HI LACKEY VOTING
LACKEY NOT VOTING.
THAT MEASURE PASSES.
ITEM NUMBER TWENTY WAS PULLED BY
THE AUTHOR.
ITEM NUMBER TWENTY ONE AS BEFORE
SEVENTY ONE WAS ON CONSENT.
ITEM TWENTY TWO SB FIVE NINETY
ONE BY SENATOR GALGIANI
KAMLAGER-DOVE [inaudible]
KAMLAGER-DOVE I ITEM NUMBER
TWENTY THREE SB SIX TWENTY WE'RE
STILL PENDING ITEM.
NUMBER TWENTY FOUR SB SIX TWENTY
ONE STILL PENDING.
ITEM NUMBER TWENTY FIVE SB SEVEN
EIGHTY ONE WAS ON CONSENT.
SO WE JUST MISSING MISTER
SANTIAGO'S BOAT SOMEONE.
GO GET MISTER SANTIAGO. FOR MR
QUIRK.
WHICHEVER IS HERE [inaudible]
PLACER DID [inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible]
YEAH.
WE HAVE ONE BILL ON CALL SB
SIXTY ONE PORTANTINO WE NEED.
THE ABSENT MEMBERS SANTIAGO
[inaudible] TO VOTE.
IT IS ON CALL
[inaudible]
THERE'S NO
YEAH TRACK [inaudible]
THANK [inaudible]
LARA [inaudible]
THERE -- WELL [inaudible]
THERE ARE --
THE
YOUR HIGH
SCHOOL IN THERE [inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible]
WELL.
A WHOLE LOT OF
SB TWENTY THREE
SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO I THAT MEASURE PASSED.
A NUMBER TO HAVE BEEN DISPENSED
WITH.
ITEM NUMBER THREE SB FORTY TWO
SANTIAGO SANTIAGO I THE MEASURE
ALSO PATH.
ITEM NUMBER FOUR SB FIFTY FIVE
IS PULLED BY AUTHOR.
ITEM NUMBER. FIVE SB SIXTY ONE
THIS MEASURE WAS ON CALL
SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO I THAT MEASURE PASSES
[inaudible]
PORTANTINO [inaudible]
PORTANTINO.
AND WE'RE SIX FULL BY AUTHOR.
ITEM NUMBER SEVEN SP ONE THIRTY
TWO QUIRK.
NO.
I DON'T NUMBER EIGHT HAS BEEN
DISPENSED WITH.
AT A NUMBER NINE HAS BEEN
ITEM NUMBER TEN SB ONE NINETY
THREE NIELSEN [inaudible]
SANTIAGO [inaudible]
SANTIAGO I ITEM NUMBER ELEVEN SB
TWO THIRTY SANTIAGO [inaudible]
SANTIAGO I NUMBER TWELVE IS ON
CONSENT.
AT A NUMBER THIRTEEN WITHOUT
I DON'T NUMBER FOURTEEN SB TWO
EIGHTY TWO BY SENATOR PELL
SANTIAGO SAN DIEGO AYE.
AT A NUMBER FIFTEEN HAS BEEN
DISPENSED WITH ITEM NUMBER.
SIXTEEN SB THREE SEVENTY FIVE
SANTIAGO SANTIAGO I I DON'T
NUMBER SEVENTEEN WAS PULLED BY
THE COMMITTEE I DON'T NUMBER.
EIGHT OKAY.
WITH A GLOBAL ATWATER.
ALL IN THE PEOPLE WHO
[inaudible]
WE NEED WELL I JUST RECENTLY.
NO WE DIDN'T REPEAT IS DOING IT.
LIKE ME AS FAR THAT.
I USE OF PULLING EVERYBODY.
SB THREE NINETY THREE I BY
SENATOR STONE SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO I I DON'T NUMBER
NINETEEN SB THREE NINETY FOUR BY
SENATOR SKINNER SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO AYE.
I DON'T EVER TWENTY WAS PULLED
BY THE AUTHOR ITEM TWENTY ONE
WAS ON CONSENT.
ITEM TWENTY TWO HAS BEEN
DISPENSED WITH.
ITEM NUMBER TWENTY THREE BUT SB
SIX TWENTY BY SENATOR PORTANTINO
SANTIAGO.
SAN DIEGO I ITEM TWENTY FOUR SB
SIX FIFTY ONE BY SENATOR GLAZER.
SANTIAGO.
SAN DIEGO I ITEM TWENTY FIVE WAS
ON CONSENT.
THANK YOU AND IT ENDS THE PUBLIC
SAFETY COMMITTEE [inaudible]
FORTY ASSEMBLY [inaudible]